Introducing the all-new Kia Nero EV. They say the first step is always the hardest, to walk into the unknown. But it's when we have the courage to step forward that the real adventure begins. With up to 407 kilometres of range on a single charge, the Kia Nero EV is a subcompact SUV that lets you travel farther and smarter. The all-new Kia Nero EV, your first step into the electric world. Kia, movement that inspires. On the 28th of February 1997, Los Angeles police officers Pirello and Farrell
Introducing the all-new Kia Nero EV. They say the first step is always the hardest, to walk into the unknown. But it's when we have the courage to step forward that the real adventure begins. With up to 407 kilometres of range on a single charge, the Kia Nero EV is a subcompact SUV that lets you travel farther and smarter. The all-new Kia Nero EV, your first step into the electric world. Kia, movement that inspires. On the 28th of February 1997, Los Angeles police officers Pirello and Farrell|||隆重推出全新起亚Nero EV。人们都说，迈出第一步总是最艰难的，那是步入未知的过程。但正是在我们鼓起勇气向前迈进时，真正的冒险才真正开始。凭借单次充电高达407公里的续航里程，起亚Nero EV是一款让您行得更远、更智能的小型SUV。全新起亚Nero EV，您迈向电动世界的第一步。起亚，激发灵感的出行。1997年2月28日，洛杉矶警察局警官皮雷洛和法雷尔
were on routine patrol driving along Laurel Canyon Boulevard, North Hollywood. As they were driving past the Bank of America, they saw two large figures dressed in black clothing entering the bank. Both were wearing ski masks, both had body armour on, and both were carrying large automatic assault rifles. Our unit officer needs help. At the Bank of America, Laurel Canyon North of Kittridge. Officer needs help.
were on routine patrol driving along Laurel Canyon Boulevard, North Hollywood. As they were driving past the Bank of America, they saw two large figures dressed in black clothing entering the bank. Both were wearing ski masks, both had body armour on, and both were carrying large automatic assault rifles. Our unit officer needs help. At the Bank of America, Laurel Canyon North of Kittridge. Officer needs help.|||正在北好莱坞的月桂峡谷大道上进行例行巡逻。当他们开车经过美国银行时，他们看到两个身穿黑衣的高大身影走进了银行。两人都戴着滑雪面罩，都穿着防弹衣，并且都携带大型自动突击步枪。我们小队的警员需要支援。在美国银行，基特里奇以北的月桂峡谷。警员需要支援。
Bank of America, Laurel Canyon North of Kittridge. Before we get to the bank, we go back to 1967. Larry Phillips Sr. was just one year out of high school when he was sent to jail for grave desecration. A drunken prank where he tried to dig up a grave and remove the head of a corpse. He was paroled in January 1968, but his freedom only lasted three months. He was sent back to jail for robbing a gas station. After just three months back in jail, he was transferred to Colorado State Hospital,
Bank of America, Laurel Canyon North of Kittridge. Before we get to the bank, we go back to 1967. Larry Phillips Sr. was just one year out of high school when he was sent to jail for grave desecration. A drunken prank where he tried to dig up a grave and remove the head of a corpse. He was paroled in January 1968, but his freedom only lasted three months. He was sent back to jail for robbing a gas station. After just three months back in jail, he was transferred to Colorado State Hospital,|||美国银行，基特里奇以北的月桂峡谷。在我们前往银行之前，让我们回到1967年。老小拉里·菲利普斯高中毕业才一年，就因亵渎坟墓而被送进监狱。这是一场酒后恶作剧，他试图挖开坟墓并取走一具尸体的头部。他在1968年1月获得假释，但他的自由只持续了三个月。他因抢劫加油站再次被送进监狱。回到监狱仅仅三个月后，他被转送到科罗拉多州立医院，
which was a psychiatric hospital. The reason for the transfer there is unknown, but after ten months, Larry Phillips Sr. had enough and he escaped. The date was the 18th of April 1969. A warrant was immediately issued for his arrest. Once he escaped, Larry Sr. picked up his girlfriend Dorothy Clay. Very little is known about Dorothy, but there are reports she herself had a criminal history with previous jail time.
which was a psychiatric hospital. The reason for the transfer there is unknown, but after ten months, Larry Phillips Sr. had enough and he escaped. The date was the 18th of April 1969. A warrant was immediately issued for his arrest. Once he escaped, Larry Sr. picked up his girlfriend Dorothy Clay. Very little is known about Dorothy, but there are reports she herself had a criminal history with previous jail time.|||那是一家精神病院。被转到那里的原因不得而知，但在十个月后，老小拉里·菲利普斯受够了，于是他逃跑了。日期是1969年4月18日。当局立即对其实施了通缉。逃跑后，老小拉里接走了他的女朋友多萝西·克莱。外界对多萝西知之甚少，但有报道称她本人有犯罪前科并曾入狱。
Both Larry Sr. and Dorothy used many different aliases to avoid detection whilst they were on the run. Not much is known about them for the next few years, but at some point they made their way to California. And it was at the California Hospital in Los Angeles on the 20th of September 1970 that Larry Phillips Jr. was born. Except the name that appeared on his birth certificate was Larry Eugene Warfell. He wouldn't be known as Larry Phillips Jr. until seven, eight years later.
Both Larry Sr. and Dorothy used many different aliases to avoid detection whilst they were on the run. Not much is known about them for the next few years, but at some point they made their way to California. And it was at the California Hospital in Los Angeles on the 20th of September 1970 that Larry Phillips Jr. was born. Except the name that appeared on his birth certificate was Larry Eugene Warfell. He wouldn't be known as Larry Phillips Jr. until seven, eight years later.|||老小拉里和多萝西在逃亡期间使用了许多不同的化名来躲避搜查。在接下来的几年里，关于他们的信息所知不多，但在某个时候他们来到了加利福尼亚。1970年9月20日，小拉里·菲利普斯在洛杉矶的加利福尼亚医院出生。只不过他出生证明上出现的名字是拉里·尤金·沃费尔。直到七八年后，他才被称为小拉里·菲利普斯。
His parents were listed on his birth certificate as Barbara Allen and Daniel Warfell. Their occupations and addresses were also fake. Larry Phillips Sr. was still on the run. They lied on the birth certificate to keep the law from catching up with them. After the birth of Larry Phillips Jr., the family disappears again. They disappear until the 22nd of September 1976. Dorothy and Larry Jr. were living in a small town near Denver. Larry Sr. wasn't living with them at the time,
His parents were listed on his birth certificate as Barbara Allen and Daniel Warfell. Their occupations and addresses were also fake. Larry Phillips Sr. was still on the run. They lied on the birth certificate to keep the law from catching up with them. After the birth of Larry Phillips Jr., the family disappears again. They disappear until the 22nd of September 1976. Dorothy and Larry Jr. were living in a small town near Denver. Larry Sr. wasn't living with them at the time,|||他的出生证明上列出的父母是芭芭拉·艾伦和丹尼尔·沃费尔。他们的职业和地址也是假的。老小拉里当时仍在逃亡。他们在出生证明上撒谎是为了防止法律追捕他们。小拉里·菲利普斯出生后，这一家人再次消失了。他们消失了，直到1976年9月22日。多萝西和小拉里住在丹佛附近的一个小镇上。老小拉里当时并没有和他们住在一起，
but he visited that day to celebrate Larry Jr.'s sixth birthday. It's unknown who tipped them off, but shortly after Larry Sr. arrived, seven FBI agents stormed the house and arrested him. He was sent back to jail to serve the rest of his sentence for the gas station robbery after being on the run for seven years. No doubt that was an experience Larry Jr. wouldn't forget. By 1980, Larry Sr. and Dorothy had divorced.
but he visited that day to celebrate Larry Jr.'s sixth birthday. It's unknown who tipped them off, but shortly after Larry Sr. arrived, seven FBI agents stormed the house and arrested him. He was sent back to jail to serve the rest of his sentence for the gas station robbery after being on the run for seven years. No doubt that was an experience Larry Jr. wouldn't forget. By 1980, Larry Sr. and Dorothy had divorced.|||但他那天去那里是为了庆祝小拉里的六岁生日。不知道是谁通风报信，老小拉里刚到不久，七名联邦调查局特工就冲进屋里将他逮捕。在逃亡七年后，他被送回监狱服完因抢劫加油站而判处的剩余刑期。毫无疑问，那是小拉里永生难忘的经历。到1980年，老小拉里和多萝西已经离婚。
During his sporadic visitation with Larry Jr., Larry Sr. passed on his anti-police and anti-establishment views. In 1986, Dorothy decided to move to Los Angeles. Larry Jr. had quit high school in the ninth grade, and he was dating a girl by the name of Sharon Santos, who would later become his wife and mother to his two children. By now, Larry Jr. had developed a love of bodybuilding. Once moving to Los Angeles,
During his sporadic visitation with Larry Jr., Larry Sr. passed on his anti-police and anti-establishment views. In 1986, Dorothy decided to move to Los Angeles. Larry Jr. had quit high school in the ninth grade, and he was dating a girl by the name of Sharon Santos, who would later become his wife and mother to his two children. By now, Larry Jr. had developed a love of bodybuilding. Once moving to Los Angeles,|||在零星探望小拉里期间，老小拉里向他灌输了反警察和反建制的观点。1986年，多萝西决定搬到洛杉矶。小拉里在九年级时就辍学了，他当时在和一个名叫莎伦·桑托斯的女孩交往，她后来成为了他的妻子和两个孩子的母亲。此时，小拉里已经对健美产生了热爱。搬到洛杉矶后，
he quickly bought a five-year membership to the world-famous Golds Gym at Venice Beach. Like so many before him, Larry Jr. had plans to make it big. He wanted to be the next Arnold Schwarzenegger. He was committed to. His trips to Golds Gym were two hours each way from where he was living. But after a few years, he realised he wasn't going to make it as a professional bodybuilder. He let his gym membership expire
he quickly bought a five-year membership to the world-famous Golds Gym at Venice Beach. Like so many before him, Larry Jr. had plans to make it big. He wanted to be the next Arnold Schwarzenegger. He was committed to. His trips to Golds Gym were two hours each way from where he was living. But after a few years, he realised he wasn't going to make it as a professional bodybuilder. He let his gym membership expire|||他很快购买了威尼斯海滩世界闻名的黄金健身房的五年会员资格。和之前的许多人一样，小拉里也有大展宏图的计划。他想成为下一个阿诺德·施瓦辛格。他为此付出了努力。从他住的地方去黄金健身房，单程就要两个小时。但几年后，他意识到自己无法成为一名职业健美运动员。他任由健身房会员资格过期，
and looked to other avenues to find his fortune. In 1990, he looked to cash in on the Los Angeles booming property market. He applied for and was granted a real estate sales license. It was granted on the grounds that he passed a future exam and that he would come up clean on a background check. It was the background check that was his undoing. A fingerprint check matched him to an arrest in 1989, where he shoplifted $400 worth of clothes.
and looked to other avenues to find his fortune. In 1990, he looked to cash in on the Los Angeles booming property market. He applied for and was granted a real estate sales license. It was granted on the grounds that he passed a future exam and that he would come up clean on a background check. It was the background check that was his undoing. A fingerprint check matched him to an arrest in 1989, where he shoplifted $400 worth of clothes.|||并寻找其他途径来发财。1990年，他希望能借洛杉矶蓬勃发展的房地产市场捞一把。他申请并获得了房地产销售执照。发放的条件是他通过未来的考试，并且背景调查没有问题。正是背景调查毁了他。指纹检查将他与1989年的一次逮捕记录匹配上，当时他偷了价值400美元的衣服。
It was his first and only arrest at the time. His bodybuilding dream didn't work out and now his planned real estate career was taken away. Larry Jr. became down and out. Instead of taking responsibility, he decided to blame everybody else. He came to resent society and its rules. He decided to move back to Denver
It was his first and only arrest at the time. His bodybuilding dream didn't work out and now his planned real estate career was taken away. Larry Jr. became down and out. Instead of taking responsibility, he decided to blame everybody else. He came to resent society and its rules. He decided to move back to Denver|||这是他当时第一次也是唯一一次被捕。他的健美梦想破灭了，现在他计划中的房地产事业也被剥夺了。小拉里变得落魄潦倒。他没有承担责任，反而决定把责任推卸给所有人。他开始怨恨社会及其规则。他决定搬回丹佛，
with his wife Sharon and his children. Larry found alternative methods to try and make it rich. He contacted local real estate agents and went through a number of properties that were for sale. He posed as a prospective buyer. He would watch the real estate agent unlock their house's lockbox, which contained the keys, and then he would memorize the combination.
with his wife Sharon and his children. Larry found alternative methods to try and make it rich. He contacted local real estate agents and went through a number of properties that were for sale. He posed as a prospective buyer. He would watch the real estate agent unlock their house's lockbox, which contained the keys, and then he would memorize the combination.|||带着他的妻子莎伦和孩子们。小拉里找到了其他方法来尝试暴富。他联系了当地的房地产经纪人，看了一套又一套待售房产。他冒充潜在买家。他会看着房地产经纪人打开装有钥匙的房屋密码箱，然后他会记住密码。
He then placed his own ads in the local paper under a fake name, claiming to have several rental properties available. People would ring him up and he would take the prospective renters and inspect the properties that were actually for sale. Larry would claim the sale of the house had gone through and the new owners wanted to rent the property out as soon as possible. He accepted down payments for rent and security deposits. But the scam didn't last long.
He then placed his own ads in the local paper under a fake name, claiming to have several rental properties available. People would ring him up and he would take the prospective renters and inspect the properties that were actually for sale. Larry would claim the sale of the house had gone through and the new owners wanted to rent the property out as soon as possible. He accepted down payments for rent and security deposits. But the scam didn't last long.|||然后他用假名在当地报纸上刊登了自己的广告，声称有几处出租房产可供选择。人们会打电话给他，他会带着潜在的租客去查看实际正在出售的房产。小拉里会声称房屋买卖已经完成，新业主希望尽快将房产出租。他接受了租金首付和押金。但这场骗局并没有持续多久。
He was arrested. He was charged with the scam, but he was released pending a sentencing hearing. Larry was looking at two years in Denver County Jail, participating in a work release program. Whilst waiting for his sentencing to be official, he split up from Sharon. It was 1992 when he walked out on her and their two kids.
He was arrested. He was charged with the scam, but he was released pending a sentencing hearing. Larry was looking at two years in Denver County Jail, participating in a work release program. Whilst waiting for his sentencing to be official, he split up from Sharon. It was 1992 when he walked out on her and their two kids.|||他被捕了。他被指控犯有诈骗罪，但在等待宣判听证会期间被释放。小拉里面临着在丹佛县监狱服刑两年并参加工作释放计划的判决。在等待正式宣判期间，他和莎伦分居了。那是1992年，他抛弃了她和两个孩子。
He didn't show up for his sentencing hearing and a warrant was issued for his arrest. It was back in 1989, while still working at a Gold's Gym in Venice Beach, where Phillip's junior met his friend Emile Mattisorano. Emile also had an interest in bodybuilding, as well as an interest in firearms. Emile was born in Romania on the 19th of July 1966.
He didn't show up for his sentencing hearing and a warrant was issued for his arrest. It was back in 1989, while still working at a Gold's Gym in Venice Beach, where Phillip's junior met his friend Emile Mattisorano. Emile also had an interest in bodybuilding, as well as an interest in firearms. Emile was born in Romania on the 19th of July 1966.|||他没有出席宣判听证会，当局对其实施了通缉。早在1989年，小菲利普斯还在威尼斯海滩的黄金健身房工作时，就在那里遇到了他的朋友埃米尔·马蒂索拉诺。埃米尔也对健美感兴趣，同时对枪支也很感兴趣。埃米尔于1966年7月19日出生于罗马尼亚。
He migrated to the USA in 1976. He went to high school at Pasadena High, where his mother says he was the victim of bullying. After finishing high school, Emile completed a three-year electronics engineering degree at university. And in 1988, Emile opened up his own computer business,
He migrated to the USA in 1976. He went to high school at Pasadena High, where his mother says he was the victim of bullying. After finishing high school, Emile completed a three-year electronics engineering degree at university. And in 1988, Emile opened up his own computer business,|||他于1976年移民到美国。他在帕萨迪纳高中读高中，他的母亲说他在那里是欺凌的受害者。高中毕业后，埃米尔在大学完成了为期三年的电子工程学位。1988年，埃米尔开启了自己的电脑生意，
selling computer parts, offering servicing and repairs, as well as writing some software. But the business was a failure and never got off the ground. He later married and had a son, but the marriage didn't last. His wife left him.
selling computer parts, offering servicing and repairs, as well as writing some software. But the business was a failure and never got off the ground. He later married and had a son, but the marriage didn't last. His wife left him.|||出售电脑配件，提供保养和维修服务，还编写了一些软件. 但这笔生意是个失败，从未真正起步。他后来结婚并生了一个儿子，但这段婚姻并没有持续多久。他的妻子离开了他。
After leaving his wife and children in Denver, Larry Phillips junior returned to Los Angeles, where he hooked back up with his buddy Emile Mattisorano. Emile, fresh off his failed business venture, and Larry, fresh off his failed bodybuilding, real estate and scam endeavors, got together to work out what they were going to do to make it rich. Or maybe a more accurate description,
After leaving his wife and children in Denver, Larry Phillips junior returned to Los Angeles, where he hooked back up with his buddy Emile Mattisorano. Emile, fresh off his failed business venture, and Larry, fresh off his failed bodybuilding, real estate and scam endeavors, got together to work out what they were going to do to make it rich. Or maybe a more accurate description,|||在把妻子和孩子留在丹佛后，小拉里·菲利普斯回到了洛杉矶，在那里他重新联系上了他的死党埃米尔·马蒂索拉诺。埃米尔刚经历失败的创业冒险，而小拉里刚经历失败的健美、房地产和诈骗尝试，两人聚在一起商量着该做点什么来发财。或者更准确的描述是，
was Larry tried to work out what he was going to do to make it rich, and how Emile was going to help. Larry had big dreams of a rich, extravagant lifestyle. This is a person who used to drive to rich neighborhoods and park outside of a house he liked, and then picture himself living there. Larry wouldn't bring anybody into his inner circle without a plan for how he could use them to his advantage.
was Larry tried to work out what he was going to do to make it rich, and how Emile was going to help. Larry had big dreams of a rich, extravagant lifestyle. This is a person who used to drive to rich neighborhoods and park outside of a house he liked, and then picture himself living there. Larry wouldn't bring anybody into his inner circle without a plan for how he could use them to his advantage.|||小拉里试图弄清楚他要做什么才能发财，以及埃米尔将如何提供帮助。小拉里对富裕、奢侈的生活方式有着宏伟的梦想。这是一个过去常常开车去富人区，把自己喜欢的一栋房子停在外面，然后想象自己住在里面的人。小拉里不会把任何人带入他的核心圈子，除非有计划说明他如何利用对方来为自己谋利。
He was the type of person that would try and break people down and build them back up, so he could control them. Larry was the manipulator, Emile was the follower. He did whatever Larry said. It was the 20th of July, 1993, when they committed their first armed robbery.
He was the type of person that would try and break people down and build them back up, so he could control them. Larry was the manipulator, Emile was the follower. He did whatever Larry said. It was the 20th of July, 1993, when they committed their first armed robbery.|||他是那种会试图摧毁人们然后再重建他们，以便自己能够控制他们的人。小拉里是操控者，埃米尔是追随者。小拉里说什么他就做什么。那是1993年7月20日，他们实施了第一次武装抢劫。
They ambushed an armored car outside a branch of First Bank in Littleton, Colorado. It was the start of a spade of robberies that would lead Larry and Emile to be dubbed the High Incident Bandits. They weren't suspects for the robbery at the time. Police had no idea. So when they were pulled over three months later,
They ambushed an armored car outside a branch of First Bank in Littleton, Colorado. It was the start of a spade of robberies that would lead Larry and Emile to be dubbed the High Incident Bandits. They weren't suspects for the robbery at the time. Police had no idea. So when they were pulled over three months later,|||他们在科罗拉多州利特尔顿的第一银行分行外伏击了一辆运钞车。这是一系列抢劫案的开始，这些抢劫案后来导致小拉里和埃米尔被称为“高频事件悍匪”。他们当时并不是这起抢劫案的嫌疑人。警方毫不知情。因此，当他们在三个月后被拦下时，
police didn't know Larry and Emile had already committed a violent armed robbery. It was the 29th of October, 1993, when Larry and Emile were pulled over in Glendale, California. Larry was driving, and Emile was in the front passenger seat. They were stopped by Sergeant Ian Grimes. When questioned, Larry said he had left his license at home, and he gave a false name.
police didn't know Larry and Emile had already committed a violent armed robbery. It was the 29th of October, 1993, when Larry and Emile were pulled over in Glendale, California. Larry was driving, and Emile was in the front passenger seat. They were stopped by Sergeant Ian Grimes. When questioned, Larry said he had left his license at home, and he gave a false name.|||警方并不知道小拉里和埃米尔已经犯下了一起暴力的武装抢劫案。那是1993年10月29日，小拉里和埃米尔在加利福尼亚州格伦代尔被拦下。小拉里在开车，埃米尔坐在前排乘客座位上。他们被伊恩·格赖姆斯警长截停。面对质问，小拉里说他的驾照忘在家里了，并报了个假名。
Sergeant Grimes then asked whose car it was, to which Emile replied it was Larry's mother's car. Sergeant Grimes had already done a check and knew it was actually an airport rental. He got Larry to step out of the car, and when he patted him down, he found a Glock pistol with an extended 33-round magazine. Then he heard a thud from inside the car.
Sergeant Grimes then asked whose car it was, to which Emile replied it was Larry's mother's car. Sergeant Grimes had already done a check and knew it was actually an airport rental. He got Larry to step out of the car, and when he patted him down, he found a Glock pistol with an extended 33-round magazine. Then he heard a thud from inside the car.|||格赖姆斯警长接着问这是谁的车，埃米尔回答说是小拉里母亲的车。格赖姆斯警长已经查过了，知道这实际上是一辆机场租赁车。他让小拉里下车，在对其实施搜身时，发现了一把配有33发加长弹匣的格洛克手枪。接着他听到车内传出一声闷响。
That was Emile dropping his own pistol underneath the passenger seat. Sergeant Grimes called for assistance and covered Larry and Emile until backup arrived. When they got there, a search of the car uncovered a semi-automatic rifle and a Springfield pistol belonging to Larry, and a semi-automatic rifle and a Colt pistol belonging to Emile. Along with the firearms,
That was Emile dropping his own pistol underneath the passenger seat. Sergeant Grimes called for assistance and covered Larry and Emile until backup arrived. When they got there, a search of the car uncovered a semi-automatic rifle and a Springfield pistol belonging to Larry, and a semi-automatic rifle and a Colt pistol belonging to Larry and Emile... Along with the firearms,|||那是埃米尔把自己的手枪扔在了乘客座位底下。格赖姆斯警长呼叫支援，并在增援赶到之前控制住小拉里和埃米尔。他们到达后，对汽车进行了搜查，发现了属于小拉里的一支半自动步枪和一把斯普林菲尔德手枪，以及属于埃米尔的一支半自动步枪和一把柯尔特手枪。除了枪支之外，
the police also found a heap of 30-round magazines, as well as a heap of 75-round drum magazines. Combined, they contained a total of 1,649 rounds of 39-millimeter ammo. They also found 967 rounds of 9-millimeter ammo, 357 rounds of 45 ammo, six smoke bombs, two improvised explosive bombs,
the police also found a heap of 30-round magazines, as well as a heap of 75-round drum magazines. Combined, they contained a total of 1,649 rounds of 39-millimeter ammo. They also found 967 rounds of 9-millimeter ammo, 357 rounds of 45 ammo, six smoke bombs, two improvised explosive bombs,|||警方还搜出了一堆30发弹匣，以及一堆75发弹鼓。两者加起来，总共包含1,649发39毫米子弹。他们还发现了967发9毫米子弹、357发45口径子弹、六枚烟雾弹、两枚简易爆炸炸弹，
two improvised explosive devices, one gas mask, two sets of body armour, two police skinners, sunglasses, gloves, wigs, ski masks, and a stopwatch, two spray cans of hair colour, three different sets of Californian license plates,
two improvised explosive devices, one gas mask, two sets of body armour, two police skinners, sunglasses, gloves, wigs, ski masks, and a stopwatch, two spray cans of hair colour, three different sets of Californian license plates,|||两个简易爆炸装置、一个防毒面具、两套防弹衣、两把警用剥皮刀（此处疑为误译或原文口误，保留字面）、太阳镜、手套、假发、滑雪面罩和一个秒表、两罐染发喷雾剂、三套不同的加州车牌，
and $1,620 in cash. They were both arrested and taken to Glendale Police Station. The police were convinced they had just stopped the bank robbery from happening, and given what was to come, they were obviously right. Larry Phillips Jr. was charged with conspiracy to commit robbery,
and $1,620 in cash. They were both arrested and taken to Glendale Police Station. The police were convinced they had just stopped the bank robbery from happening, and given what was to come, they were obviously right. Larry Phillips Jr. was charged with conspiracy to commit robbery,|||以及1,620美元现金。两人均被捕并被带到格伦代尔警察局。警方确信他们刚刚阻止了一起银行抢劫案的发生，鉴于即将发生的事情，他们显然是对的。小拉里·菲利普斯被控串谋抢劫、
brand theft auto, unlawful weapons activity, carrying a loaded concealed firearm, and felony perjury. Emile Mattisorano was charged with conspiracy to commit robbery, unlawful weapons activity, and carrying a loaded firearm in a vehicle.
brand theft auto, unlawful weapons activity, carrying a loaded concealed firearm, and felony perjury. Emile Mattisorano was charged with conspiracy to commit robbery, unlawful weapons activity, and carrying a loaded firearm in a vehicle.|||重大汽车盗窃、非法武器活动、携带上膛的隐蔽枪支以及重罪伪证罪。埃米尔·马蒂索拉诺被控串谋抢劫、非法武器活动以及在车内携带上膛的枪支。
At their preliminary hearing, the grand theft auto charge and the perjury charge against Larry were dropped. On the remaining charges, they were facing eight years jail each. The problem was, neither Larry or Emile said a word, and the police had no other information to go on.
At their preliminary hearing, the grand theft auto charge and the perjury charge against Larry were dropped. On the remaining charges, they were facing eight years jail each. The problem was, neither Larry or Emile said a word, and the police had no other information to go on.|||在他们的初步听证会上，针对小拉里的重大汽车盗窃指控和伪证指控被撤销。对于剩下的指控，他们每人面临八年监禁。问题是，小拉里和埃米尔都没有说一句话，警方也没有其他信息可资利用。
So it was difficult to prove they were going to commit a robbery. Even though that was the logical conclusion, given the arsenal and the disguises they were found with, there was another thing to prove it in court. At their arraignment, they gave a story that the disguises
So it was difficult to prove they were going to commit a robbery. Even though that was the logical conclusion, given the arsenal and the disguises they were found with, there was another thing to prove it in court. At their arraignment, they gave a story that the disguises|||因此很难证明他们打算实施抢劫。尽管考虑到搜出的军火库和伪装，这是符合逻辑的结论，但在法庭上还有另一件事需要证明。在提审时，他们编造了一个故事，称这些伪装
were in preparation for a Halloween party, and that they had the weapons in ammo because they were headed to a shooting range. In exchange for early guilty pleas, the DA dropped their conspiracy robbery charges, and allowed Larry and Emile to plead to much lesser charges. Larry was sentenced to 99 days jail
were in preparation for a Halloween party, and that they had the weapons in ammo because they were headed to a shooting range. In exchange for early guilty pleas, the DA dropped their conspiracy robbery charges, and allowed Larry and Emile to plead to much lesser charges. Larry was sentenced to 99 days jail|||是为了万圣节派对做准备，他们带着武器和弹药是因为他们正前往靶场。作为对提前认罪的交换，地方检察官撤销了他们的串谋抢劫指控，并允许小拉里和埃米尔对轻得多的罪名认罪。小拉里被判处99天监禁，
with three years probation. Both were actually released straight away due to time already served. The date was the 27th of December, 1993. Larry was still wanted in Denver on the rental property scam, but for unknown reasons, Denver authorities didn't pursue him.
with three years probation. Both were actually released straight away due to time already served. The date was the 27th of December, 1993. Larry was still wanted in Denver on the rental property scam, but for unknown reasons, Denver authorities didn't pursue him.|||缓刑三年。由于已经服刑的时间，两人实际上立即就被释放了。日期是1993年12月27日. 小拉里因出租房产诈骗案仍在丹佛遭到通缉，但出于不明原因，丹佛当局没有对其实施追捕。
He wasn't extradited back there to face punishment, so essentially, Larry was a free man. It was a big crime, but it was about 18 months later, on the 14th of June, 1995, that Larry and Emile hit another armored car. Herman Cook was a guard working for Brink Security. He was working on an armored car
He wasn't extradited back there to face punishment, so essentially, Larry was a free man. It was a big crime, but it was about 18 months later, on the 14th of June, 1995, that Larry and Emile hit another armored car. Herman Cook was a guard working for Brink Security. He was working on an armored car|||他没有被引渡回那里接受惩罚，所以从本质上讲，小拉里是一个自由人. 这是一起大罪，但大约18个月后的1995年6月14日，小拉里和埃米尔袭击了另一辆运钞车。赫尔曼·库克是布林克保安公司的一名保安。他在一辆运钞车上工作，
doing cash drop-offs and pickups to banks. Herman had just made a drop-off to the Bank of America on Roscoe Boulevard, Winnetcar, Los Angeles. He was walking back to the armored car with an empty money bag. It was here that Herman was completely ambushed, shot multiple times, without warning in a completely unprovoked attack.
doing cash drop-offs and pickups to banks. Herman had just made a drop-off to the Bank of America on Roscoe Boulevard, Winnetcar, Los Angeles. He was walking back to the armored car with an empty money bag. It was here that Herman was completely ambushed, shot multiple times, without warning in a completely unprovoked attack.|||负责向银行运送和提取现金。赫尔曼刚刚在洛杉矶温内特卡罗斯科大道的美洲银行完成了一笔现金投递。他拿着一个空钱袋走回运钞车。正是在这里，赫尔曼完全陷入了埋伏，在毫无预兆、完全无端挑起的袭击中身中数枪。
Herman staggered his way back to the front of the armored car where he collapsed. He was never even able to draw his firearm. His partner, Felipe Cortez, was in the armored car at the time. Emile then opened fire on the car while Larry made the approach. Felipe was able to get a few shots off.
Herman staggered his way back to the front of the armored car where he collapsed. He was never even able to draw his firearm. His partner, Felipe Cortez, was in the armored car at the time. Emile then opened fire on the car while Larry made the approach. Felipe was able to get a few shots off.|||赫尔曼踉踉跄跄地走回运钞车前，然后倒在了地上。他甚至连拔枪的机会都没有。他的搭档费利佩·科尔特斯当时正在运钞车内。随后，埃米尔向汽车开火，而小拉里则步步逼近。费利佩得以开了几枪。
He said he even hit one of them, but it did nothing but stagger them. A clear sign they were wearing body armor. Felipe was also shot in the attack. Larry was able to reach into the car and grab a bag of money. He and Emile then escaped, making off with $122,000.
He said he even hit one of them, but it did nothing but stagger them. A clear sign they were wearing body armor. Felipe was also shot in the attack. Larry was able to reach into the car and grab a bag of money. He and Emile then escaped, making off with $122,000.|||他说他甚至击中了其中一人，但这除了让他们踉跄一下之外毫无作用。这清楚地表明他们穿着防弹衣。费利佩也在袭击中中枪。小拉里得以把手伸进车里抓走了一袋钱。他和埃米尔随后逃跑，劫走了122,000美元。
Felipe survived, but Herman wasn't so lucky. He died as a result of his gunshot wounds. After that robbery, Larry and Emile decided to change tactics. They decided to go for banks. No more armored cars. On the 2nd of May 1996,
Felipe survived, but Herman wasn't so lucky. He died as a result of his gunshot wounds. After that robbery, Larry and Emile decided to change tactics. They decided to go for banks. No more armored cars. On the 2nd of May 1996,|||费利佩幸存了下来，但赫尔曼就没有那么幸运了。他因枪伤身亡。那次抢劫后，小拉里和埃米尔决定改变战术。他们决定对银行下手。不再抢运钞车了。1996年5月2日，
just before 10am, Larry and Emile burst through the doors of the Bank of America on Woodman Avenue, Van Nuys. Both were armed with automatic rifles. After yelling at everyone, get on the fucking floor. Emile started shooting through the armored teller door.
just before 10am, Larry and Emile burst through the doors of the Bank of America on Woodman Avenue, Van Nuys. Both were armed with automatic rifles. After yelling at everyone, get on the fucking floor. Emile started shooting through the armored teller door.|||上午10点前不久，小拉里和埃米尔冲进范内伊斯伍德曼大道美国银行的大门。两人都手持自动步枪。在大喊“都他妈趴在地上”之后，埃米尔开始隔着防弹柜台门开枪。
Due to the type of weapon and caliber of bullet Emile was using, he shot the door open easily. He yelled out for the manager who identified herself. He forced her to open the vault and Emile started filling up a large bag with cash.
Due to the type of weapon and caliber of bullet Emile was using, he shot the door open easily. He yelled out for the manager who identified herself. He forced her to open the vault and Emile started filling up a large bag with cash.|||由于埃米尔使用的武器类型和子弹口径，他轻易地将门射穿。他大声叫经理出来，经理表明了自己的身份。他强迫经理打开金库，埃米尔开始往一个大袋子里装满现金。
Larry remained out in the four-year area of the bank, keeping an eye on the customers and other staff members. They were inside the bank for around six minutes and managed to get away with $755,048. Only four weeks later, on May 31st, Larry and Emile burst through the doors
Larry remained out in the four-year area of the bank, keeping an eye on the customers and other staff members. They were inside the bank for around six minutes and managed to get away with $755,048. Only four weeks later, on May 31st, Larry and Emile burst through the doors|||小拉里留在银行的大厅区域（此处4-year为语音转写错误，译为大厅），密切注视着客户和其他员工。他们在银行呆了大约六分钟，成功抢走了755,048美元。仅仅四周后的5月31日，小拉里和埃米尔冲进大门，
of the Bank of America on Roscoe Boulevard, Winnicka. The same bank they had robbed the armored V&E outside of, killing Herman Cook about a year earlier. Very similar to the previous bank robbery, they yelled at everybody to get down. One of the tellers managed to hit the soil and alarm before diving onto the floor.
of the Bank of America on Roscoe Boulevard, Winnicka. The same bank they had robbed the armored V&E outside of, killing Herman Cook about a year earlier. Very similar to the previous bank robbery, they yelled at everybody to get down. One of the tellers managed to hit the soil and alarm before diving onto the floor.|||目标是温尼卡罗斯科大道的美洲银行。大约一年前，他们曾在该银行外部抢劫运钞车并杀害了赫尔曼·库克。与之前的银行抢劫案非常相似，他们大喊让每个人都趴下。其中一名出纳员在扑倒在地之前，设法按下了警报器（soil and alarm为语音转写错误，实为silent alarm）。
Emile shot his way through the teller door, grabbed the manager and forced her to open the vault. Two bank employees were struck by ricochets, but they survived. Emile was screaming at the manager to fill up his bag. He was becoming agitated at the amount of money that was in the vault, or the lack of money.
Emile shot his way through the teller door, grabbed the manager and forced her to open the vault. Two bank employees were struck by ricochets, but they survived. Emile was screaming at the manager to fill up his bag. He was becoming agitated at the amount of money that was in the vault, or the lack of money.|||埃米尔一路开枪打穿柜台门，抓住经理并强迫她打开金库。两名银行员工被流弹击中，但他们活了下来。埃米尔冲着经理尖叫，让她把袋子装满。他对金库里的钱数（或者说钱太少）感到越来越烦躁。
He kept screaming, where's the rest of it? And he made several threats to kill the manager. What had happened was that Larry and Emile had done surveillance on the bank and saw what they thought was a cash delivery from an armored car. What they had actually seen was a cash pickup. That's why there wasn't as much money in the vault
He kept screaming, where's the rest of it? And he made several threats to kill the manager. What had happened was that Larry and Emile had done surveillance on the bank and saw what they thought was a cash delivery from an armored car. What they had actually seen was a cash pickup. That's why there wasn't as much money in the vault|||他不停地尖叫：“剩下的在哪儿？”并多次威胁要杀死经理。发生的情况是，小拉里和埃米尔对该银行进行了监视，看到了他们认为是运钞车运送现金的情景。而他们实际看到的是现金提取。这就是为什么金库里的钱没有他们计划的那么多
as they had planned. Despite being disappointed in the haul, they still managed to steal $794,200, although there were several marked bills in amongst the cash. They got lucky that day, too. The police were thin on the ground, and it took them much longer to respond to the alarm than usual.
as they had planned. Despite being disappointed in the haul, they still managed to steal $794,200, although there were several marked bills in amongst the cash. They got lucky that day, too. The police were thin on the ground, and it took them much longer to respond to the alarm than usual.|||正如他们所计划的那样。尽管对战利品感到失望，他们还是成功偷走了794,200美元，尽管现金中夹杂着几张做了记号的钞票。那天他们也很走运。警力单薄，警方对警报做出响应花费的时间比平时长得多。
Larry and Emile were in the bank for close to eight minutes. Most other days, the police would have been there by then. But on this occasion, they weren't, and they managed to get away. The police still had no suspects for the robberies. They had a nickname, though. The high-incident bandits. But nobody knew who they were.
Larry and Emile were in the bank for close to eight minutes. Most other days, the police would have been there by then. But on this occasion, they weren't, and they managed to get away. The police still had no suspects for the robberies. They had a nickname, though. The high-incident bandits. But nobody knew who they were.|||小拉里和埃米尔在银行呆了将近八分钟。在大多数其他日子里，警察在那时早该到了。但在这次事件中，他们没有到场，而劫匪成功逃脱了。警方对这些抢劫案仍然没有嫌疑人。不过他们有一个绰号——高频事件悍匪。但没有人知道他们是谁。
It would be nine months before they struck again. Branch 384 of the Bank of America is located at 6600 Laurel Canyon Boulevard, North Hollywood. Larry and Emile had done their homework, staking out the bank, learning the layout, formulating their plan, and observing armored car drop-offs and pickups.
It would be nine months before they struck again. Branch 384 of the Bank of America is located at 6600 Laurel Canyon Boulevard, North Hollywood. Larry and Emile had done their homework, staking out the bank, learning the layout, formulating their plan, and observing armored car drop-offs and pickups.|||九个月后，他们再次作案。美国银行第384分行位于北好莱坞月桂峡谷大道6600号。小拉里和埃米尔做足了功课，踩点银行、熟悉布局、制定计划，并观察运钞车的投递和提取。
They arrived at the bank about 9.15 a.m. Emile drove the white chef with black-and-dark windows into the northern parking lot via Archwood Street. They weren't mucking around. Larry was wearing a Kevlar body armour vest, a groin protector, and by using additional vests, he had made improvised armour for his shins, thighs, and forearms.
They arrived at the bank about 9.15 a.m. Emile drove the white chef with black-and-dark windows into the northern parking lot via Archwood Street. They weren't mucking around. Larry was wearing a Kevlar body armour vest, a groin protector, and by using additional vests, he had made improvised armour for his shins, thighs, and forearms.|||他们在上午9点15分左右到达银行。埃米尔驾驶着那辆车窗涂黑的白色雪佛兰（chef为语音转写错误，实为Chevrolet），经由阿奇伍德街驶入北侧停车场。他们可不是在胡闹。小拉里穿着凯夫拉防弹背心、护裆，并且通过使用额外的背心，为自己的小腿、大腿和前臂制作了简易护甲。
His upper arms weren't protected, but he was still pretty well covered. The body armour weighed 43 pounds in total, or about 20 kilos. He also wore a load-bearing vest that contained ammunition pouches, as well as a belt that contained several canteen pouches, which is where he store his ammunition drums in
His upper arms weren't protected, but he was still pretty well covered. The body armour weighed 43 pounds in total, or about 20 kilos. He also wore a load-bearing vest that contained ammunition pouches, as well as a belt that contained several canteen pouches, which is where he store his ammunition drums in|||他的上臂没有受到保护，但他仍然被包裹得相当严实。这套防弹衣总重43磅，约合20公斤。他还穿了一件带有弹药袋的战术承重背心，以及一条带有几个水壶袋的腰带，他在那里存放弹鼓用于自动步枪。
for the automatic rifles. He also had a shoulder holster, which was carrying a pistol. He wore black gloves with a watch face glued to the back of the left glove. He was dressed in long black pants and a long-slave dark-coloured shirt with a black jacket over the top.
for the automatic rifles. He also had a shoulder holster, which was carrying a pistol. He wore black gloves with a watch face glued to the back of the left glove. He was dressed in long black pants and a long-slave dark-coloured shirt with a black jacket over the top.|||他还配有一个肩式枪套，里面装着一把手枪。他戴着黑色手套，左手手套背面粘着一个表盘。他身穿黑色长裤和一件深色长袖衬衫，外面套着一件黑色夹克。
Emile was virtually dressed the same, with a very similar setup, right down to the glued watch face on the back of his glove. Although he didn't have quite as much body armour as Larry, his legs and arms weren't as well protected. As if they didn't look intimidating enough, they were both of a very large build.
Emile was virtually dressed the same, with a very similar setup, right down to the glued watch face on the back of his glove. Although he didn't have quite as much body armour as Larry, his legs and arms weren't as well protected. As if they didn't look intimidating enough, they were both of a very large build.|||埃米尔的穿着几乎一模一样，装备也非常相似，甚至连手套背面粘着的表盘都一样。尽管他的防弹衣没有小拉里那么多，但他的腿部和手臂受到的保护也没有那么好。就好像他们看起来还不够吓人似的，两人的体格都非常健硕。
Remember, it was their interest in bodybuilding that allowed them to meet, and as they had done with the previous robberies, they covered their faces with black ski masks. Between them, they had three AK-47-style fully automatic assault rifles with 100-ground ammo drums, as well as two other assault rifles.
Remember, it was their interest in bodybuilding that allowed them to meet, and as they had done with the previous robberies, they covered their faces with black ski masks. Between them, they had three AK-47-style fully automatic assault rifles with 100-ground ammo drums, as well as two other assault rifles.|||记住，正是对健美的兴趣让他们相遇，而且就像他们之前抢劫时所做的那样，他们用黑色滑雪面罩遮住了脸。他们两人一共拥有三支带有100发弹鼓的AK-47风格全自动突击步枪，以及另外两支突击步枪。
The rifles had been illegally modified to fire fully automatic. They also had two 9mm handguns and a .38 calibre revolver. Between them, they had close to 3,000 rounds of ammo, including armour-piercing rounds. These were weapons that were designed for war. They set their watches for a time of eight minutes.
The rifles had been illegally modified to fire fully automatic. They also had two 9mm handguns and a .38 calibre revolver. Between them, they had close to 3,000 rounds of ammo, including armour-piercing rounds. These were weapons that were designed for war. They set their watches for a time of eight minutes.|||这些步枪经过非法改装，可以进行全自动射击。他们还拥有两把9毫米手枪和一把.38口径左轮手枪。他们两人一共携带了近3,000发子弹，包括穿甲弹。这些都是为战争而设计的武器。他们将手表设定为八分钟倒计时。
The maximum time they believed they had until police would arrive. They then made their move. Armed with an AK-47 assault rifle each, they walked to the northern doorway of the bank, a distance of about 32 feet or 10 metres from where they had parked. The time was 9.17am.
The maximum time they believed they had until police would arrive. They then made their move. Armed with an AK-47 assault rifle each, they walked to the northern doorway of the bank, a distance of about 32 feet or 10 metres from where they had parked. The time was 9.17am.|||这是他们认为在警察赶到之前所拥有的最长时间。然后他们采取了行动。他们每人手持一把AK-47突击步枪，走向银行的北门，距离他们停车的地方大约32英尺或10米。时间是上午9点17分。
They left their other assault rifles in the shed, along with a police radio. As they were entering the bank, an LAPD North Hollywood patrol vehicle was driving down Laurel Canyon Boulevard, just on a routine patrol. Pure luck. Right place at the right time.
They left their other assault rifles in the shed, along with a police radio. As they were entering the bank, an LAPD North Hollywood patrol vehicle was driving down Laurel Canyon Boulevard, just on a routine patrol. Pure luck. Right place at the right time.|||他们把其他突击步枪留在了车里（shed为语音转写错误，实指雪佛兰车内），随身还带了一台警用无线电。正当他们进入银行时，一辆洛杉矶警察局北好莱坞的巡逻车正沿着月桂峡谷大道行驶，进行例行巡逻。纯属运气。在对的时间出现在对的地方。
Or wrong place, depending on which way you look at it. The patrol car was being driven by Officer Perello. Officer Farrell was in the passenger seat. After spotting Larry and Emil, they swung the police car into the southern parking lot of the Bank of America and took up positions behind their patrol car,
Or wrong place, depending on which way you look at it. The patrol car was being driven by Officer Perello. Officer Farrell was in the passenger seat. After spotting Larry and Emil, they swung the police car into the southern parking lot of the Bank of America and took up positions behind their patrol car,|||或者说在错的时间出现在错的地方，这取决于你从哪个角度看。巡逻车由皮雷洛警官驾驶。法雷尔警官坐在副驾驶座上。在发现小拉里和埃米尔后，他们将警车驶入美洲银行的南侧停车场，并在巡逻车后方占据有利位置，
covering the bank. Farrell then made the first broadcast. There was a foyer containing three ATMs at the northern entrance to the bank. A customer was using one of the ATMs when he felt somebody approach him from behind. Turning around, he got quite the shock when he saw Larry and Emil.
covering the bank. Farrell then made the first broadcast. There was a foyer containing three ATMs at the northern entrance to the bank. A customer was using one of the ATMs when he felt somebody approach him from behind. Turning around, he got quite the shock when he saw Larry and Emil.|||掩护银行。法雷尔随即进行了第一次广播。银行北门有一个包含三台自动取款机的门厅。一名顾客正在使用其中一台自动取款机时，突然感觉有人从背后靠近。他转过身去，看到小拉里和埃米尔时吓了一大跳。
Larry Phillips said, Okay, motherfucker, let's go. Not about to argue, the customer went willingly with Larry and Emil and walked inside the bank with them. As soon as they entered the bank, Emil started pouring his rifle into the roof, yelling, Everyone down.
Larry Phillips said, Okay, motherfucker, let's go. Not about to argue, the customer went willingly with Larry and Emil and walked inside the bank with them. As soon as they entered the bank, Emil started pouring his rifle into the roof, yelling, Everyone down.|||小拉里·菲利普斯说：“好了，混蛋，我们走。”顾客不想争辩，情愿地跟着小拉里和埃米尔，和他们一起走进了银行。他们一进入银行，埃米尔就开始用步枪朝屋顶疯狂射击，大喊：“所有人趴下！”
Larry yelled, This is a fucking hold up. Everyone down, motherfuckers. Nobody argued. Although one of the tellers was able to hit the hold up alarm before diving to the floor. The shot's coming, shot's coming, open the door! The suspects are in the bank.
Larry yelled, This is a fucking hold up. Everyone down, motherfuckers. Nobody argued. Although one of the tellers was able to hit the hold up alarm before diving to the floor. The shot's coming, shot's coming, open the door! The suspects are in the bank.|||小拉里大喊：“这他妈是抢劫。所有人趴下，你们这群混蛋。”没有人争辩。尽管其中一名出纳员在扑倒在地之前设法按下了劫案警报。枪声来了，枪声来了，开门！嫌疑人在银行里。
The suspects are inside of the bank. The two of them are in progress inside the bank. The bank of America, lower the friction load. Lower canyon north of Kittridge, the suspects are inside of the bank. Just like the previous bank robberies, Emil approached the teller door
The suspects are inside of the bank. The two of them are in progress inside the bank. The bank of America, lower the friction load. Lower canyon north of Kittridge, the suspects are inside of the bank. Just like the previous bank robberies, Emil approached the teller door|||嫌疑人在银行里面。他们两人正在银行内部作案。美洲银行，降低摩擦载荷（lower the friction load为语音转写对 Laurel Canyon 的严重误听）。基特里奇以北的月桂峡谷，嫌疑人在银行里面。就像以前的银行抢劫案一样，埃米尔走近柜台门，
and shot his way through it. The door was bullet resistant, designed to stop any pistol round. But it was no match for Emil's high-power automatic assault rifle. Once he got through the door, Emil yelled, Get the money or we will kill you.
and shot his way through it. The door was bullet resistant, designed to stop any pistol round. But it was no match for Emil's high-power automatic assault rifle. Once he got through the door, Emil yelled, Get the money or we will kill you.|||开枪打穿了它。这扇门是防弹的，旨在挡住任何手枪子弹。但它根本抵挡不住埃米尔的大功率自动突击步枪。一进门，埃米尔就大喊：“把钱拿出来，否则我们杀了你。”
Joe Villagrana, the branch's assistant manager, got up and made himself known. Emil aimed the rifle at him and told him to open the vault. As they were making their way there, Emil struck him in the back of the head with the rifle. There were about 30 people in the bank in total.
Joe Villagrana, the branch's assistant manager, got up and made himself known. Emil aimed the rifle at him and told him to open the vault. As they were making their way there, Emil struck him in the back of the head with the rifle. There were about 30 people in the bank in total.|||分行副经理乔·比拉格拉纳站起身来表明了自己的身份。埃米尔用步枪指着他，让他打开金库。在他们朝那边走去时，埃米尔用步枪击中了乔的后脑勺。银行里总共大约有30人。
In court, there were about 30 people in the bank in total, including five people in the safety deposit box room. As Emil and Joe walked past that room heading towards the vault, Emil shot off more rounds into the roof, screaming at the people in the safety deposit box room to get out.
In court, there were about 30 people in the bank in total, including five people in the safety deposit box room. As Emil and Joe walked past that room heading towards the vault, Emil shot off more rounds into the roof, screaming at the people in the safety deposit box room to get out.|||（法庭记录显示）银行里总共大约有30人，其中包括保险箱室里的五个人。当埃米尔和乔走过该房间前往金库时，埃米尔又向屋顶开了几枪，冲着保险箱里的人尖叫让他们滚出去。
Larry remained out in the lobby of the bank, keeping control of the customers and other employees. Meanwhile, Officer Farrell kept the radio transmissions coming, telling the other police where he wanted people set up. T3, I want one unit on the north side, I want a unit on the south side, and I want a unit on the south, if possible. 1589 is just running car three,
Larry remained out in the lobby of the bank, keeping control of the customers and other employees. Meanwhile, Officer Farrell kept the radio transmissions coming, telling the other police where he wanted people set up. T3, I want one unit on the north side, I want a unit on the south side, and I want a unit on the south, if possible. 1589 is just running car three,|||小拉里留在银行大厅里，控制着顾客和其他员工。与此同时，法雷尔警官不断进行无线电广播，告诉其他警察他希望把警力部署在什么地方。T3，我希望北侧有一支分队，南侧有一支分队，如果可能的话，南边再要一支分队。1589正在支援3号车，
T3, can you note the picture? 1583 wants the unit on the north side, on the south side and on the rear. T3, we want someone to position themselves safely to lock the front door. We don't think the suspect's only in here. 1592 is requesting a unit to safely position themselves in front of the front door.
T3, can you note the picture? 1583 wants the unit on the north side, on the south side and on the rear. T3, we want someone to position themselves safely to lock the front door. We don't think the suspect's only in here. 1592 is requesting a unit to safely position themselves in front of the front door.|||T3，你能注意一下现场情况吗？1583号要求北侧、南侧和后方都要有分队。T3，我们需要有人找安全的位置把前门锁死。我们认为嫌疑人不只在这里。1592请求派出一支分队安全地部署在前门正前方。
If the suspect's possibly do not know, see, he is there. The next officers to arrive on scene were detectives Tracey Angela's and William Krulak. They arrived about 9.19am and pulled up in a parking lot opposite the bank's entrance, on the western side. Sergeant
If the suspect's possibly do not know, see, he is there. The next officers to arrive on scene were detectives Tracey Angela's and William Krulak. They arrived about 9.19am and pulled up in a parking lot opposite the bank's entrance, on the western side. Sergeant|||如果嫌疑人可能不知道、看不到他在那儿。下一批到达现场的警官是侦探特雷西·安杰利斯和威廉·克鲁拉克。他们在大约上午9点19分到达，并将车停在银行入口对面西侧的停车场里。警长
Larry Haines was next on scene. He blocked off the intersection of Laurel Canyon Boulevard and Archwood Street, which was north of the bank. So he had a view of the door Larry and Emile had entered. It's believed that Larry and Emile had no idea the police were outside at this time. They didn't have their police radio with them.
Larry Haines was next on scene. He blocked off the intersection of Laurel Canyon Boulevard and Archwood Street, which was north of the bank. So he had a view of the door Larry and Emile had entered. It's believed that Larry and Emile had no idea the police were outside at this time. They didn't have their police radio with them.|||拉里·海恩斯是下一个到达现场的。他封锁了位于银行北侧的月桂峡谷大道和阿奇伍德街的交叉口。因此他可以看到小拉里和埃米尔进入的那扇门。据信，小拉里和埃米尔当时根本不知道外面有警察。他们没有随身携带警用无线电。
They left that out in the chef. There were a few civilian witnesses hanging outside the bank. Tracey Fisher, Michael Horan and Barry Golding. They saw Sergeant Haines arrive and they all approached him to let him know what they had seen and heard. I don't believe the advising.
They left that out in the chef. There were a few civilian witnesses hanging outside the bank. Tracey Fisher, Michael Horan and Barry Golding. They saw Sergeant Haines arrive and they all approached him to let him know what they had seen and heard. I don't believe the advising.|||他们把它留在了车里（chef同前，指雪佛兰）。银行外面有几个平民目击者：特雷西·费舍尔、迈克尔·霍兰和巴里·戈尔丁。他们看到海恩斯警长到达，便纷纷走上前去，告诉他他们所看到和听到的一切。我不相信通报内容。
If two witnesses over here say there's possibly two and three suspects in size, possibly AK-47s are wearing ski masks and dark clothing. Pitching out 40 advisers or two correction witnesses at the location vises two to three, suspects inside the bank wearing ski masks and AK-47s. Less than 30 seconds later,
If two witnesses over here say there's possibly two and three suspects in size, possibly AK-47s are wearing ski masks and dark clothing. Pitching out 40 advisers or two correction witnesses at the location vises two to three, suspects inside the bank wearing ski masks and AK-47s. Less than 30 seconds later,|||如果这里的两名目击者说可能有两到三个嫌疑人规模，可能带着AK-47，戴着滑雪面罩和深色衣服。现场播报40名顾问（Pitching out 40 advisers为语音转写错误）或两名目击证人称，该地点有两到三名嫌疑人在银行内部，戴着滑雪面罩并持有AK-47。不到30秒后，
Larry walked out of the bank. He must have been tipped somehow that the police were there, possibly hearing sorens or seeing a patrol car. Sergeant Haines made this broadcast. I think somebody just came out of the front door of the Bank of America. The advising unknown person has exited the bank. Larry walked out of the northern exit.
Larry walked out of the bank. He must have been tipped somehow that the police were there, possibly hearing sorens or seeing a patrol car. Sergeant Haines made this broadcast. I think somebody just came out of the front door of the Bank of America. The advising unknown person has exited the bank. Larry walked out of the northern exit.|||小拉里走出了银行。他一定是通过某种方式得知警察在那里的，可能是听到了警笛声（sorens为sirens的误拼）或看到了巡逻车。海恩斯警长进行了这样一番广播：“我想刚有人从美洲银行的前门出来了。通报称有不明人员已经离开银行。”小拉里从北出口走了出来。
He casually looked around and surveyed the scene, not looking concerned at all. From his position, he probably would have only been able to see the patrol car of Sergeant Haines. So it might not have looked that bad to him. But there were other police there, not to mention the large amount still on the way.
He casually looked around and surveyed the scene, not looking concerned at all. From his position, he probably would have only been able to see the patrol car of Sergeant Haines. So it might not have looked that bad to him. But there were other police there, not to mention the large amount still on the way.|||他漫不经心地环顾四周并观察现场，看起来一点也不担心。从他的位置来看，他可能只能看到海恩斯警长的巡逻车。所以对他的局势来说可能没那么糟。但现场还有其他警察，更不用说大量正在赶来的警力了。
After having a look around, Larry turned around and calmly walked back inside the bank. Shortly after this, Officer Martin Whitfield arrived and parked next to Sergeant Haines. While this was going on, the meal had gained entry to the vault, but progress was slow due to the cash being separated into different lockable boxes.
After having a look around, Larry turned around and calmly walked back inside the bank. Shortly after this, Officer Martin Whitfield arrived and parked next to Sergeant Haines. While this was going on, the meal had gained entry to the vault, but progress was slow due to the cash being separated into different lockable boxes.|||环顾四周后，小拉里转过身，镇定自若地走回了银行里面。此后不久，马丁·惠特菲尔德警长到达并停在海恩斯警长旁边。正当这一切发生时，埃米尔（meal为Emile的语音误写）已经进入了金库，但由于现金被分装在不同的带锁箱子里，进展很慢。
This was designed to slow down bank robberies, and it was working. Once he walked back inside the bank, Larry walked over to a security guard who was lying down on the lobby floor. He put his foot on his neck, pointed his rifle at him, and said, If you move, motherfucker, I will kill you.
This was designed to slow down bank robberies, and it was working. Once he walked back inside the bank, Larry walked over to a security guard who was lying down on the lobby floor. He put his foot on his neck, pointed his rifle at him, and said, If you move, motherfucker, I will kill you.|||这是为了延缓银行抢劫而设计的，而且确实起到了作用。一走回银行内部，小拉里就走向一个躺在大厅地上的保安。他把脚踩在保安的脖子上，用步枪指着他，说道：“你要是敢动一下，混蛋，我弄死你。”
When I tell you, I want you to move all these people to the vault. The security guard nodded. Larry then walked off, shooting his rifle into the roof, screaming, Nobody look at me, or I will kill you. Back inside the vault, a meal was becoming furious.
When I tell you, I want you to move all these people to the vault. The security guard nodded. Larry then walked off, shooting his rifle into the roof, screaming, Nobody look at me, or I will kill you. Back inside the vault, a meal was becoming furious.|||等我下令时，我要你把所有人转移到金库里去。保安点了点头。小拉里随后走开，对着屋顶开枪，尖叫道：“谁都不准看我，否则我杀了你。”在金库里面，埃米尔（meal同前）变得暴怒起来。
There was nowhere near the amount of money you thought there would be. Due to the large amount of recent robberies, including the two advanced knives and winnet car, that Larry and a meal had committed, the Bank of America had changed its delivery schedule. The North Hollywood branch
There was nowhere near the amount of money you thought there would be. Due to the large amount of recent robberies, including the two advanced knives and winnet car, that Larry and a meal had committed, the Bank of America had changed its delivery schedule. The North Hollywood branch|||这里的钱远没有他们想象的那么多。由于最近发生了大量抢劫案（包括小拉里和埃米尔犯下的两起高级持刀/运钞车抢劫，此处 advanced knives 为 armored cars 的语音误写），美洲银行更改了其送货时间表。北好莱坞分行
still hadn't received their cash delivery. He started firing his weapon out of frustration. The police outside the bank could hear all this automatic gunfire being let off. The call was put in for SWAT to attend. Employees, four shots have been fired from the second bank. Switching out 40 more shots are being fired from the suspect
still hadn't received their cash delivery. He started firing his weapon out of frustration. The police outside the bank could hear all this automatic gunfire being let off. The call was put in for SWAT to attend. Employees, four shots have been fired from the second bank. Switching out 40 more shots are being fired from the suspect|||仍然没有收到现金配送。他由于沮丧开始开枪射击。银行外面的警察能听到所有这些自动枪声。有关部门接到呼叫要求特警队（SWAT）出动。员工们，第二家银行已经开了四枪。切换播报：嫌疑人正在开出另外40多枪，
at Laurel Canyon North of Kitchwich at the Bank of America. 50 and L.O.K. are requesting a SWAT reply on this location. Requesting 18 names for SWAT. Police had the bank surrounded. Officer Haynes and Whitfield were at the intersection of Laurel Canyon Boulevard and Archwood Street to the north. They had a good view of the northern doorway. Officer Brentlinger was east of their position,
at Laurel Canyon North of Kitchwich at the Bank of America. 50 and L.O.K. are requesting a SWAT reply on this location. Requesting 18 names for SWAT. Police had the bank surrounded. Officer Haynes and Whitfield were at the intersection of Laurel Canyon Boulevard and Archwood Street to the north. They had a good view of the northern doorway. Officer Brentlinger was east of their position,|||地点位于基特里奇以北的月桂峡谷美洲银行。50号和L.O.K.请求特警队对该地点作出回应。请求18名特警人员（18 names为语音误写）。警方包围了银行。海恩斯和惠特菲尔德警官在北侧的月桂峡谷大道和阿奇伍德街交叉口。他们能很好地观察到北门。布伦特林格警官在他们位置的东侧，
covering the north-eastern side of the bank. First officers on the scene, Farrell and Pirello, were still in position in the southern parking lot. Detectives Krulak and Angela's had been joined by officers of Warravan and Officer Guy in the parking lot opposite the bank on the western side. And there were still plenty more police officers on the way. Back inside the vault,
covering the north-eastern side of the bank. First officers on the scene, Farrell and Pirello, were still in position in the southern parking lot. Detectives Krulak and Angela's had been joined by officers of Warravan and Officer Guy in the parking lot opposite the bank on the western side. And there were still plenty more police officers on the way. Back inside the vault,|||负责掩护银行的东北侧。现场的第一批警官法雷尔和皮雷洛仍然坚守在南侧停车场的位置。侦探克鲁拉克和安杰利斯在银行西侧对面的停车场里与瓦拉万警官和盖伊警官会合。还有大量警察在赶来的路上。回到金库里面，
Joe had placed $303,305 inside Emile's bag. But in amongst all that cash were three die packs. Emile walked out of the vault towards the teller door. Larry yelled out to a bank employee. Open the door. Open the fucking door. She complied. Larry then yelled to the security guard
Joe had placed $303,305 inside Emile's bag. But in amongst all that cash were three die packs. Emile walked out of the vault towards the teller door. Larry yelled out to a bank employee. Open the door. Open the fucking door. She complied. Larry then yelled to the security guard|||乔已经把303,305美元放进了埃米尔的袋子里。但在所有这些现金中夹杂着三个染料包。埃米尔走出了金库，朝柜台门走去。小拉里冲着一名银行员工大喊：“开门。把他妈的门打开。”她照做了。小拉里随后朝保安大喊，
that it was time to move the people to the vault. Larry and Emile had been inside the bank for seven minutes. It was now 9.24am. And it was at this time that Larry burst through the northern door of the bank, looking straight up towards the intersection of Archwood Street and Laurel Canyon Boulevard, where officers Haines and Whitfield were. Without a second of hesitation, Larry opened fire. First at Haines Patrol Car.
that it was time to move the people to the vault. Larry and Emile had been inside the bank for seven minutes. It was now 9.24am. And it was at this time that Larry burst through the northern door of the bank, looking straight up towards the intersection of Archwood Street and Laurel Canyon Boulevard, where officers Haines and Whitfield were. Without a second of hesitation, Larry opened fire. First at Haines Patrol Car.|||是时候把人转移到金库里去了。小拉里和埃米尔在银行里已经呆了七分钟。现在是上午9点24分。正是在这个时候，小拉里冲出了银行的北门，直视着阿奇伍德街和月桂峡谷大道的交叉口，海恩斯和惠特菲尔德警官就在那里。小拉里毫不犹豫地开火了。首先朝着海恩斯的巡逻车开枪。
The three civilian witnesses were still in that area too. They all immediately died for cover when the shooting started. Whitfield was behind his patrol car, which was parked next to Haines. Larry took aim at that and unleashed on him as well. The bullets easily ripped through the car and struck Officer Whitfield. Pitching out Haines, what has been notified? Everybody stay down and wrap an automatic fire. The pan in the area was fired.
The three civilian witnesses were still in that area too. They all immediately died for cover when the shooting started. Whitfield was behind his patrol car, which was parked next to Haines. Larry took aim at that and unleashed on him as well. The bullets easily ripped through the car and struck Officer Whitfield. Pitching out Haines, what has been notified? Everybody stay down and wrap an automatic fire. The pan in the area was fired.|||那三名平民目击者也还在那个区域。枪声一响，他们立刻趴下寻找掩护。惠特菲尔德躲在他停在海恩斯车旁边的巡逻车后面。小拉里瞄准那里，也向他疯狂倾泻火力。子弹轻易地撕裂了汽车，击中了惠特菲尔德警官。播报海恩斯情况，收到了什么通知？所有人趴下并遭到自动火力压制。该地区的平底锅（the pan 为语音转写错误）开了火。
Everybody, I just have to do that. Just fire it. Only automatic weapons, but why is that? I was in Haines House, Pitching out 40s, requesting help. Pitching out 40 your location. What was the bank? Our unit, I know United United, rises large, shots fired. 500 block of Laurel Canyon.
Everybody, I just have to do that. Just fire it. Only automatic weapons, but why is that? I was in Haines House, Pitching out 40s, requesting help. Pitching out 40 your location. What was the bank? Our unit, I know United United, rises large, shots fired. 500 block of Laurel Canyon.|||大家，我必须这么做。直接开火。只有自动武器，但为什么会这样？我在海恩斯住所，播报40，请求支援。播报40您的位置。哪家银行？我们的小队，我认识联合（United），情况重大，有枪声。月桂峡谷500号街区。
Pitching out all units, officers requesting help. Laurel Canyon, North of Kitchwich, at the Bank of America, shots are being fired. All units, officer requested help at the bank. Pitching out. Pitching out. Pitching out. Pitching out. Pitching out.
Pitching out all units, officers requesting help. Laurel Canyon, North of Kitchwich, at the Bank of America, shots are being fired. All units, officer requested help at the bank. Pitching out. Pitching out. Pitching out. Pitching out. Pitching out.|||播报所有单位，有警员请求支援。月桂峡谷，基特里奇以北，美国银行，有枪声。所有单位，有警员在银行请求支援。播报。播报。播报。播报。播报。
America, stay down, shots are being fired. Automatic fire. Pitching out. Pitching out. What is being notified? Call three all officers, stay down. Shots are being fired from AK-47. There is an officer down.
America, stay down, shots are being fired. Automatic fire. Pitching out. Pitching out. What is being notified? Call three all officers, stay down. Shots are being fired from AK-47. There is an officer down.|||美洲银行，趴下，有枪击发生。自动火力。播报。播报。通报了什么？呼叫3号，所有警官，趴下。AK-47正在开枪。有警官倒下了。
Pitching out. Officer down. Officer fired. Our unit, I'm Pitching out. Laurel Canyon, Kitchwich up. Pitching out. Pitching out. Laurel Canyon, Kitchwich up.
Pitching out. Officer down. Officer fired. Our unit, I'm Pitching out. Laurel Canyon, Kitchwich up. Pitching out. Pitching out. Laurel Canyon, Kitchwich up.|||播报。警官倒下。警官中枪。我们小队，我正在播报。月桂峡谷，基特里奇上方。播报。播报。月桂峡谷，基特里奇上方。
Pitching out. Pitching out. As Larry started firing to the North, Officer Zboravan saw an opportunity. He was to the south-west of him, taking cover behind the locksmith's chaos, with Officer Guy and detectives Krulak and the Angelids. So in effect, Larry almost had his back turned
Pitching out. Pitching out. As Larry started firing to the North, Officer Zboravan saw an opportunity. He was to the south-west of him, taking cover behind the locksmith's chaos, with Officer Guy and detectives Krulak and the Angelids. So in effect, Larry almost had his back turned|||播报。播报。正当小拉里开始向北开火时，兹博拉万警官看到了一个机会。他在小拉里的西南方，带着盖伊警官以及侦探克鲁拉克和安杰利斯，在锁匠铺（locksmith's chaos为locksmith's shop的语音误写）后面寻找掩护。所以实际上，小拉里几乎是把后背转向了
to Zboravan's position. Zboravan took the opportunity. He stepped out from behind his cover and fired two shots from his pump action shotgun. Some of the pellets did strike Larry in the back. One even found a gap in his body armour and struck him directly. The hit caused Larry to stumble,
to Zboravan's position. Zboravan took the opportunity. He stepped out from behind his cover and fired two shots from his pump action shotgun. Some of the pellets did strike Larry in the back. One even found a gap in his body armour and struck him directly. The hit caused Larry to stumble,|||兹博拉万的位置。兹博拉万抓住了这个机会。他从掩护后走出来，用他的泵动式霰弹枪开了两枪。一些弹丸确实击中了小拉里的背部。甚至有一颗找到了他防弹衣的缝隙，直接击中了目标。这次击中导致小拉里踉跄了一下，
but he didn't fall. He turned around to face Zboravan, who by now was making his way back behind the locksmith's chaos. Larry opened up on the chaos, firing over 100 rounds into the building. It was very flimsy cover. Bullets were going through the walls easily,
but he didn't fall. He turned around to face Zboravan, who by now was making his way back behind the locksmith's chaos. Larry opened up on the chaos, firing over 100 rounds into the building. It was very flimsy cover. Bullets were going through the walls easily,|||但他没有倒下。他转过身面对兹博拉万，后者此时正退回锁匠铺后面。小拉里向锁匠铺疯狂开火，向建筑内发射了100多发子弹。那是极其脆弱的掩护。子弹轻易地穿过了墙壁，
ricocheting everywhere. The officers hit the ground. Zboravan and Guy had body armour, but the two detectives didn't. Realising this, Zboravan placed his body over the top of Detective Angela's. And only a few seconds later,
ricocheting everywhere. The officers hit the ground. Zboravan and Guy had body armour, but the two detectives didn't. Realising this, Zboravan placed his body over the top of Detective Angela's. And only a few seconds later,|||到处都是流弹横飞。警官们扑倒在地。兹博拉万和盖伊有防弹衣，但两名侦探没有。意识到这一点后，兹博拉万用自己的身体护住了侦探安杰利斯。仅仅几秒钟后，
he was shot twice. He started bleeding heavily. We're in a hill right here with the officers down. Get up. You're going to get an attack alert here. Any of you that know how many officers are down, we have one. More than one.
he was shot twice. He started bleeding heavily. We're in a hill right here with the officers down. Get up. You're going to get an attack alert here. Any of you that know how many officers are down, we have one. More than one.|||他身中两枪。他开始大量出血。我们现在遇到大麻烦了（hill为hell的语音误拼），有警官倒下了。起来。你们这里会收到攻击警报。你们中间有谁知道有多少警官倒下了，我们有一个。不止一个。
More than one. There's more than one officer down, so I don't think that's a nice attack alert. We're going to get an attack alert here. Go for it. Get the tank alert going. Open it. 5541,
不止一个。不止一个警察倒下了，所以我觉得这不是一个普通的袭击警报。我们这里要发布袭击警报了。行动吧。启动坦克警报。打开它。5541，
the officer has been hit. We are declaring an attack alert. RA is en route. What is being notified to airlift? After unloading on the locksmith chaos, Larry turned around back to the north. Back towards Whitfield, Haynes and the three civilian witnesses.
警员中弹了。我们宣布进入袭击警报。救援救护车（RA）正在赶往途中。空运正在通知什么？在锁匠混乱处卸完子弹后，拉里转身向北折返。朝着惠特菲尔德、海恩斯和三名平民目击者走去。
Haynes was broadcasting on the police radio when Larry opened fire again. This time he struck Haynes, hitting him in the upper left arm. The patrol car was offering only minimal protection. The bullets were destroying it and mostly going straight through it. Tracy Fisher could see her cupboard dwindling away.
当拉里再次开火时，海恩斯正在警用对讲机上广播。这一次他击中了海恩斯，打中了海恩斯的左大臂。巡逻车只能提供极微弱的保护。子弹正在摧毁它，而且大部分直接穿透了它。特雷西·费舍尔眼睁睁看着她藏身的掩体逐渐减少。
She tried to make a run for it, but she was struck in the foot before she got anywhere. She dropped back down behind the patrol car. Horan had also been struck with a bullet. So there was now three people behind the patrol car of Haynes who had been wounded, including Haynes himself. Back behind the locksmith chaos,
她试图逃跑，但在跑出多远之前脚部就中弹了。她退回并蹲在巡逻车后面。霍兰也中弹了。因此，海恩斯的巡逻车后面现在有三个人受伤，包括海恩斯本人。在锁匠混乱处的后方，
Detective Krulak asked officers of Borovan if he could run. Despite being shot, the Borovan said he could. They tried to get the safety using vehicles in the parking lot as cover, but Larry spotted them and unleashed more bullets. They were hit and cut with a glass and other fragments of the cars and the ground.
克鲁拉克探员问博罗万警官他是否能跑。尽管受了枪伤，博罗万说他可以。他们试图利用停车场里的车辆作掩护寻找安全地点，但拉里发现了他们并倾泻了更多子弹。他们中弹了，被玻璃以及汽车和地面的其他碎片割伤。
Krulak was struck in the right ankle. They managed to spot a doorway and made a run for it. Larry still peppering them with bullets. They managed to crash through it. They didn't have time to stop and open the door, so they just dived right through the glass. The doorway was an entrance to a dentist's surgery. Also using the cars as cover,
克鲁拉克右脚踝中弹。他们设法发现了一个门廊并逃了过去。拉里依然向他们倾泻子弹。他们设法撞了进去。他们没有时间停下来开门，所以直接一头扎过了玻璃。这个门廊是一家牙医诊所的入口。同样利用汽车作掩护，
Detective Angela's and officer Guy tried to escape as well. Larry turned his attention to them and sprayed them with bullets. They dived for cover behind the cars. The total time Larry had been firing at the police was about three minutes. During that time, he fired approximately 300 rounds and wounded several officers and civilians. At 9.27am, Larry walked back inside the bank.
安吉拉探员和盖伊警官也试图逃跑。拉里将注意力转向他们，并向他们疯狂扫射。他们跳进汽车后面寻找掩护。拉里向警方开火的总时间大约是三分钟。在此期间，他发射了大约300发子弹，打伤了几名警察和平民。上午9点27分，拉里走回了银行内部。
The police had no answer for that onslaught. One officer put it best when he said I was in the wrong place with the wrong gun. The bullets the police were using were incapable of penetrating Larry's body armour. And as most of his body was covered with body armour, the police were basically no chance of striking him. Larry, on the other hand, had an automatic assault rifle
警方对这种猛烈的攻击毫无招架之力。一名警官说得最好，他说我在错误的时间、带着错误的枪出现在了错误的地方。警方使用的子弹无法穿透拉里的防弹衣。由于他的大部分身体都被防弹衣覆盖，警方基本上没有机会击中他。另一方面，拉里有一支自动突击步枪，
with armour piercing rounds that were going straight through the police cars and walls with ease. It wasn't a fair fight. As Larry walked back inside the bank, Zabora Van was calling out for help inside the dentist's surgery. Dr Montice came to his aid. Detective Krulak was inside covering the entrance, just in case Larry decided to come after them.
带有穿甲弹，能够轻而易举地直接穿透警车和墙壁。这不是一场公平的战斗。当拉里走回银行时，扎博万正在牙医诊所里大声呼救。蒙蒂斯医生前来施救。克鲁拉克探员在里面守住入口，以防拉里决定追杀过来。
Outside, more and more officers were arriving, taking up positions around the perimeter. At 9.30am, Larry walked back outside. This time, he had a meal with him. They both carried the bag of money through the doorway. As they walked out the door, they both opened fire. So this time, there were two people shooting at Officer Guy and Detective Angeles.
在外面，越来越多的警察赶到，在周边地区占据位置。上午9点30分，拉里再次走回外面。这一次，他随身带了一个包。他们俩都提着装钱的袋子穿过门廊。当他们走出门口时，两人同时开火。所以这一次，有两个人向盖伊警官和安吉拉探员开枪。
Upstairs in the dentist's office, Zabora Van was looking out the window and he could see what was going on. He yelled into the police radio. Officer Guy, I'm coming behind you! Officer Guy entered the building behind you. He was trying to direct his fellow officer to safety, but Officer Guy was pinned down by the heavy fire.
在楼上的牙医诊家里，扎博万正向窗外望去，他能看到外面发生了什么。他对着警用电台大喊：“盖伊警官，我从你后面过来了！盖伊警官进入了你后面的建筑物。”他试图指引他的同僚去安全地带，但盖伊警官被猛烈的火力死死压制住了。
The bullets ripped through the car he was taking cover behind and he was struck in the right thigh. He took off his gun belt and used it as a makeshift tourniquet, which would actually save his life. Detective Angeles was also wounded. The police were basically helpless at this point. Most of the original responders had been wounded. SWAT still hadn't arrived.
子弹穿透了他作为掩体的汽车，他的右大腿中弹了。他解下枪带，把它当作临时止血带，这实际上救了他的命。安吉拉探员也受伤了。此时警方基本上束手无策。大部分第一批赶到的救援人员都已受伤。特警队（SWAT）仍未抵达。
They were actually on a training exercise at the police academy when the call came through. Larry and Amiel continued to fire at anything that moved. Despite being completely surrounded, they calmly left the entrance of the bank and walked out into the open. Already wounded officers Haynes and Whitfield were still behind their patrol cars with the three civilians
当电话打进来时，他们实际上正在警察学院进行军事训练。拉里和埃米尔继续向任何移动的目标开火。尽管被完全包围，他们还是冷静地离开银行入口，大步走到了开阔地带。已经受伤的警官海恩斯和惠特菲尔德仍然和三名平民一起躲在巡逻车后面，
when they saw Larry and Amiel leave the bank and they were actually moving towards their position. They made a quick decision to try and protect the civilians and draw the fire away from them. So Haynes and Whitfield got up and ran during the fire towards them. Haynes managed to reach a nearby tree line taking cover, but he was wounded again in the left shin.
当他们看到拉里和埃米尔离开银行时，发现他们实际上正朝自己的位置移动。他们迅速做出决定，试图保护平民并将火力吸引开。于是海恩斯和惠特菲尔德站起身来，在枪林弹雨中朝着他们冲去。海恩斯设法到达附近的一排树木后寻求掩护，但他的左小腿再次中弹。
Whitfield took cover behind a nearby tree, but not before being shot through the thigh. The bullets shattered his femur, putting him in a really bad way. He managed to crawl his way to behind the tree. Not satisfied with badly wounding him, Larry and Amiel continued to fire heavily in his direction. They were trying to finish him off.
惠特菲尔德躲在附近的一棵树后，但在此之前大腿已经中弹。子弹粉碎了他的股骨，情况极其糟糕。他勉强爬到了树后。拉里和埃米尔对将他重伤并不满足，继续向他的方向猛烈开火。他们正试图结果他的性命。
There were now officers down everywhere. I need an eye on you and please help improve the building before the parking lot. Officers requesting help in the building before the parking lot are possibly also having multiple officers down at Victory and Artwood. All you need to check for an open night. Whitfield, get back.
现在到处都有警察倒下。我需要有人盯着，请在停车场前帮忙疏通大楼。要求在停车场前的大楼里支援的警官，在维多利亚和阿特伍德交界处可能也有多名警官倒下。你们所有人都要检查是否有开着的夜间通道。惠特菲尔德，退后。
Haynes, I just requested help. What is your location? The builder's parking lot? Affirmative, Affirmative, south of Hughes in the parking lot and in the building. Multiple officers hit. Multiple officers hit in the building south of, south of Hughes Market.
海恩斯，我刚请求了支援。你们的位置在哪？建筑工地的停车场？收到，收到，休斯市场南边的停车场和建筑物里。多名警察中弹。休斯市场南边的大楼里有多名警察中弹。
Multiple officers hit. They're sending in a tank for the officers. There's some people on the right side of the bank. On the north side of the bank. Oh yeah, this is a city-wide tack alert. We are now on tack alert due to that unusual occurrence in North Hollywood Division. A city-wide tack alert this time.
多名警察中弹。他们正派坦克去接应警察。银行右侧有一些人。在银行北侧。哦，对了，这是一次全市范围的袭击警报。由于北好莱坞分局发生的不寻常事件，我们现在正处于袭击警报中。这次是全市范围的袭击警报。
It's out further north. Media helicopters had started to arrive by now and they were capturing the first pictures of this madness that would be broadcast around the world. A police helicopter was also circling above, giving updates on what they could see from the air. Larry carried the bag containing the money to the chef. Amir was still shooting, offering Larry covering fire.
它延伸到了更北的地方。此时，媒体直升机已经开始抵达，他们正在拍摄这场将在全球转播的疯狂事件的第一批画面。一架警用直升机也在上方盘旋，播报他们从空中看到的最新情况。拉里提着装钱的袋子走向雪佛兰轿车。埃米尔仍在射击，为拉里提供掩护火力。
By now the die packs had exploded, but a lot of the money was still actually usable. It wasn't all ruined. Larry dropped the bag next to the chef and grabbed some more ammunition. Amir wasn't too far behind him. They're going to the north. They're going to the front. How north?
此时防盗染色包已经爆炸，但许多钱实际上仍然可以使用。并不是全部都毁了。拉里把袋子扔在雪佛兰车旁，抓起更多弹药。埃米尔离他也不远。他们去北方了。他们去前面了。多北？
The suspects are exiting through the north front. Damn. Suspect on the north side of the building. Walk around like nothing. They've got AK-47s, two of them in the back. Heavy body armor. The suspects are exiting the bank on the north side of the building armed with AK-47s wearing heavy body armor.
嫌疑人正从北侧正面出口撤离。该死。嫌疑人在大楼北侧。大摇大摆地走着，就像没事一样。他们有AK-47，后备箱里有两把。穿着重型防弹衣。嫌疑人正从大楼北侧走出银行，手持AK-47，穿着重型防弹衣。
Yes, Larry. These guys are firing at the officers. They're all obsessed with stand-back. All officers, you've got party air units. The suspects are firing at all officers. Stay down, party air units. As Amir was making his way to the chef, he was grazed above the right eye with a bullet.
是的，拉里。这些家伙在向警察开火。他们全神贯注于坚守阵地。所有警员，你们有空中单位支援。嫌疑人正在向所有警员开火。趴下，空中单位。当埃米尔走向雪佛兰时，一颗子弹擦过了他的右眼上方。
The wound was only a few millimeters away from killing him. He was extremely lucky. He dropped a one knee behind the chef while he assessed the damage. Once he realized it was OK, he jumped into the chef. He also had a gunshot wound to the calf by now. Larry, though, didn't seem too interested in getting in the car. He was still shooting at anything and everything. By now, a lot more officers were on scene,
这个伤口离夺走他的性命只有几毫米之遥。他非常幸运。他在雪佛兰车后单膝跪地，评估伤势。一旦意识到没事，他便跳进了雪佛兰里。此时他的小腿也中了枪。然而，拉里似乎对上车逃跑不太感兴趣。他仍在向任何和所有东西开枪。此时，现场有更多的警察，
and he himself was being fired upon from multiple positions. He was shot at least three times in this particular exchange, but none of the bullets put him down. The body armor was still holding out. Suspect, you guys are ready to get it? One suspect is in the right vehicle. One suspect is in the right vehicle. The right vehicle, that's the west.
他自己也正受到多个位置的射击。在这次特定的交火中，他至少中弹三次，但没有一颗子弹能将他击倒。防弹衣依然在起作用。嫌疑人，你们准备好拿下了吗？一个嫌疑人在右侧车辆里。一个嫌疑人在右侧车辆里。右边的车，那是西边。
The right vehicle is on the west side of the bank. One suspect is still firing at the officers to the rear location. All officers, stay down. One suspect is still firing at the rear of the bank. One suspect is in the right vehicle on the west side of the bank. Whilst waiting for SWAT to arrive, the North Hollywood watch commander put a call out for any available officers to go to a nearby B&B gun store and get some bigger guns
右边的车在银行西侧。一名嫌疑人仍在向后方位置的警察开火。所有警员，趴下。一名嫌疑人仍在向银行后方开火。一名嫌疑人在银行西侧的右侧车里。在等待特警队到达的同时，北好莱坞的值班指挥官呼叫任何可用的警员前往附近的B&B枪械店获取一些威力更大的枪支，
that would have the ability to get through Larry and Emile's body armor. There's nothing we rather can stop them. To any unit that is available to go to B&B and pick up some weapons, they're requesting someone to go to BAD and pick up weapons. 50 yards down, do you have any body available to go to B&B guns? Hang on, SWAT unit, come in. There's 41 who are spotted at B&B guns. Special agent is going.
这些枪支将有能力穿透拉里和埃米尔的防弹衣。没有什么能比这更好地阻止他们了。致任何有空前往B&B并拿一些武器的单位，他们请求有人去BAD拿武器。前方50码处，你们有任何人可以去B&B枪店吗？等等，特警单位，请讲。有41号在B&B枪店被发现。特工正在前往。
15 crash 41 is going to get guns. Several units responded to the call. The store wasn't open when they got there, but they managed to get the staff's attention who were inside. They opened up and the shop owner instructed his staff to give the police whatever they wanted. Larry made his way back to the shav and swapped weapons. Why he didn't get into the car to start the getaway at this point?
15号紧急赶往41号去拿枪。几个单位响应了呼叫。他们到达时店里没开门，但他们设法引起了里面工作人员的注意。店门打开了，店老板指示他的员工给警察任何他们想要的武器。拉里回到雪佛兰车旁并交换了武器。为什么他此时没有上车开始逃跑？
Nobody knows. Instead, he took a knee in front of the shav, aimed upward and started firing at the helicopters. Larry was shot again, but the body armor was still holding up. He continued firing non-stop. Emile opened the passenger door beckoning for Larry to get in. The body armor was still holding up. Emile opened the passenger door beckoning for Larry to get in,
没人知道。相反，他跪在雪佛兰车前，向上瞄准并开始向直升机开枪。拉里再次中弹，但防弹衣依然顶用了。他继续不停地开火。埃米尔打开副驾驶车门，示意拉里上车。防弹衣依然顶用了。埃米尔打开副驾驶车门，示意拉里上车，
but Larry slammed the door shut. He was intent to stay outside the shav and provide covering fire. Suspect has retrieved additional weapons from the truck of his vehicle. Suspect is retrieving additional weapons from the vehicle and shots are being fired. Suspect is walking along. He's in the base. He's trying to get them to come after him.
但拉里猛地关上了车门。他铁了心要留在雪佛兰外面提供掩护火力。嫌疑人从他汽车的卡车后备箱里取出了额外的武器。嫌疑人正在从车里取出额外的武器，枪声正在响起。嫌疑人正顺着路走。他在基地里。他正试图引诱他们追过来。
He's got additional weapons. The truck is open on his vehicle. The guy out there, if somebody has a shot, take it. Suspect has. Line Suspect is walking east of the bank. Fifteen out ten advised that someone has a shot. Take it. Suspect taken.
他有额外的武器。他的车后备箱是开着的。外面的那个家伙，如果有人有射击机会，就开枪。嫌疑人有。排队。嫌疑人正走在银行东侧。15号出10号建议有人有机会就开枪。开枪。嫌疑人已被拿下。
The guy is also going down. He's got heavy body armor. Open the head. The suspect has heavy body armor to offer to our firing element. He's not going down. Despite taking multiple hits, Larry still wasn't going down. The body armor was too effective. That left only one place to aim.
这家伙也要倒下了。他穿着重型防弹衣。打头部。嫌疑人有重型防弹衣来抵挡我们的火力。他没有倒下。尽管多次中弹，拉里仍然没有倒下。防弹衣太有效了。这使得只有一个地方可以瞄准。
The call was put out to aim for the head. Meanwhile, Officer Whitfield had been keeping radio contact, but it was starting to get touch and go. We have an officer down victory west of Law Canyon. He needs help. Call three. He is passing out. Two officers who responded to the Officer Down Call
发出了瞄准头部的指令。与此同时，惠特菲尔德警官一直在保持无线电联系，但情况开始变得岌岌可危。我们在劳峡谷西侧的维多利亚路段有一名警官倒下。他需要帮助。呼叫3号。他快晕过去了。响应“警官倒下”呼叫的两名警官
were Anthony Kabunok and Todd Schmitz. I believe what happened is they were responding to Officer Whitfield's call. But in doing so, they came across Detective Angela's and Officer Guy, who were in charge of the officer down call. They were in charge of the officer down call. They were in charge of the officer down call.
是安东尼·卡布诺克和托德·施密茨。我相信发生的情况是他们正在响应惠特菲尔德警官的呼叫。但在这样做的过程中，他们遇到了安吉拉探员和盖伊警官，他们负责处理警官倒下的呼叫。他们负责处理警官倒下的呼叫。他们负责处理警官倒下的呼叫。
They were in charge of the officer down call. They were in charge of the officer down call. They treated Angela's and Officer Guy, who were also wounded and still pinned down, taking cover in the parking lot opposite the bank. Officer Kabunok grabbed Officer Guy and pulled him up into the car. Detective Angela was able to get herself in.
他们负责处理警官倒下的呼叫。他们负责处理警官倒下的呼叫。他们救治了安吉拉和盖伊警官，他们也受了伤，仍然被压制住，在银行对面的停车场里寻找掩护。卡布诺克警官抓住盖伊警官把他拉进车里。安吉拉探员设法自己上了车。
Officer Schmitz then reversed harshly back out of the parking lot and got Angela's and Guy medical help. It's around this time that SWAT arrived. They immediately got to work rescuing the other injured officers and the injured civilians. They got hold of an armored car to assist in the rescue. The officer that's down at Lowell Canyon Archwood is unconscious. Shots are being fired still. The officer is down at Archwood and Lowell Canyon. 40 is about 30 yards north of Archwood on Lowell Canyon.
施密茨警官随后猛烈地倒车驶出停车场，并将安吉拉和盖伊送去就医。正是在这个时候，特警队到达了。他们立即开始工作，营救其他受伤的警察和受伤的平民。他们弄到了一辆装甲车来协助救援。在洛厄尔峡谷阿特伍德倒下的警官已经不省人事了。枪声仍在响。在阿特伍德和洛厄尔峡谷有警官倒下。40号在洛厄尔峡谷上阿特伍德以北大约30码处。
30 yards north of Archwood or Lowell Canyon. The officer is down unconscious. 40 is an officer that's behind the tree and he's got cover. The officer that's down has gotten cover behind the tree. The RA has been notified we're trying to get someone in for him. 50 is an armored car coming in with an armored car coming in full of police officers. The officer is moving. The officer is moving. Emil put the chev in motion deciding it was time to try and leave. The officer is moving. The officer is moving.
在阿特伍德或洛厄尔峡谷以北30码处。倒下的警官不省人事。40号是一名在树后且有掩护的警察。倒下的警察已经在树后找到了掩护。已经通知了救援救护车（RA），我们正试图派人进去接他。50号是一辆装载着警察的装甲车正在开进来。警察在移动。警察在移动。埃米尔启动了雪佛兰，决定是时候尝试离开这里了。警察在移动。警察在移动。
Emil drove slowly and Larry walked next to the car continuing to shoot at anything he could. Eventually they slowly made their way out of the parking lot turning right onto Archwood Street. Larry is still walking next to the chev. Larry walked along the footpath beside a large truck with a long trailer that was parked on the side of the road. Emil continued driving east on Archwood but officers were waiting. Larry got shot twice more. Forcing him back to take cover behind the truck trailer. But Emil was still driving east so they were now separated.
埃米尔缓慢地开车，拉里走在车旁，继续向他能看到的任何东西射击。最终，他们慢慢驶离停车场，右转进入阿特伍德街。拉里仍然走在雪佛兰旁边。拉里沿着人行道走，旁边停着一辆停在路边、挂着长拖车的卡车。埃米尔继续向东开往阿特伍德，但警察们正在等待。拉里又中了两枪。迫使他退回并躲在卡车拖车后面。但埃米尔还在向东开，所以他们现在分开了。
We've got one suspect driving the white vehicle. He's down from the north parking lot. We've got one suspect down foot. The suspect down foot is behind a long trailer. Truck trailer rigged. This way out here. Right here. Swat is driving and moving out of the way. Swat is moving in.
我们有一个嫌疑人开着白色车辆。他从北停车场下来了。我们有一个嫌疑人徒步倒下。徒步倒下的嫌疑人在一辆长拖车后面。卡车拖车挂车。从这出去。就在这。特警队正在开车并移开。特警队正在开进。
There's one suspect eastbound from the north side of the parking lot in the vehicle. The other one is off foot near the long trailer. Swat is en route to 6600 Low Canyon across from Del Taco for the off foot down. Officer is moving eastbound. They're moving eastbound to Archwood. The suspect is moving eastbound near Archwood. Officer Torres had a clear shot and unloaded 12 bullets into the chev. The shots caused Emil to accelerate harshly creating an even bigger gap between him and his partner.
停车场北侧有一名嫌疑人驾车向东行驶。另一个人在长拖车附近徒步。特警队正赶往洛厄尔峡谷6600号（Del Taco对面）去处理徒步倒下的嫌疑人。警察正向东移动。他们正向东移动到阿特伍德。嫌疑人在阿特伍德附近向东移动。托雷斯警官看准时机，向雪佛兰倾泻了12发子弹。这些枪击导致埃米尔猛踩油门，在他和他的同伙之间拉开了更大的差距。
Larry was in big trouble back behind the truck trailer. Suffering from several bad gunshot wounds one of which was going to be fatal if he didn't get attended to. Now his rifle jammed as well. And he couldn't clear it. He dropped the rifle and pulled out a Beretta pistol and started walking east again along Archwood. The suspect is walking toward one street east of Low Canyon from Archwood. The suspect is moving eastbound. Way up ahead he could see Emil still in the chev.
卡车拖车后面的拉里陷入了巨大的麻烦。身受数处严重枪伤，如果不加以治疗，其中一处将是致命的。现在他的步枪也卡壳了。而且他无法排除故障。他扔下步枪，掏出一把贝雷塔手枪，沿着阿特伍德再次向东走去。嫌疑人正从阿特伍德朝洛厄尔峡谷以东的一条街道走去。嫌疑人正向东移动。前方不远处，他看到埃米尔还在雪佛兰车里。
Emil wasn't waiting no. He had his own problems being pursued by other officers. And at least seven officers stood in Larry's path. Larry continued firing at them with the Beretta but he was shot yet again. He was now suffering about 11 gunshot wounds. The latest one struck him in the hand which caused him to drop the pistol. He picked it back up off the ground, put it under his chin and shot himself in the head. He died instantly.
埃米尔没有等他。他有自己的麻烦，正被地面上的其他警察和空中的直升机追赶。至少有七名警察挡在拉里的路上。拉里继续用贝雷塔向他们开枪，但他又一次中枪了。他现在大约受了11处枪伤。最近的一枪击中了手部，导致他把手枪掉在了地上。他又把它从地上捡起来，放在下巴底下，对着自己的头部开了一枪。他当场死亡。
Larry Phillips Jr. was 26 years old. Meanwhile up the road Emil was closely being followed by police on the ground and helicopters in the air. He quickly realized he needed to swap cars as the chev was leaking fuel, had flat tyres and wouldn't be drivable for much longer. He was still driving east on Archwood Street when a red Ford sedan drove towards him. Obviously seeing the shut up vehicle and Emil behind the wheel, the red Ford started to reverse. Emil got out of his chev and motioned for the red Ford to come back. It didn't. So Emil started firing at it.
小拉里·菲利普斯年仅26岁。与此同时，在前方不远处的路上，埃米尔正紧紧被地面的警察和空中的直升机尾随。他很快意识到自己需要换车，因为雪佛兰正在漏油，轮胎也瘪了，开不了多久了。他仍然沿着阿特伍德街向东行驶，这时一辆红色的福特轿车朝他驶来。红色福特的司机显然看到了这辆千疮百孔的车和坐在方向盘后面的埃米尔，于是开始倒车。埃米尔从雪佛兰里出来，示意红色福特回来。车没有回来。于是埃米尔开始向它开枪。
All of this was being caught on footage. Times were getting desperate for Emil and to get away was now looking close to impossible. He got back into the chev and just sat there doing nothing. He sat there for over 10 seconds before finally acting again. He put the chev into drive and continued east along Archwood Street. He found another target. A 1962 Jeep Gladiator being driven by Bill Ma. Emil started firing through the windscreen at the Jeep.
这一切都被镜头捕捉到了。埃米尔的情况变得绝望，逃跑现在看起来几乎是不可能了。他回到雪佛兰里，坐在那里什么也没做。他坐在那里十多秒钟，然后才再次采取行动。他把雪佛兰挂入前进档，继续沿阿特伍德街向东行驶。他又找到了一个目标。一辆由比尔·马驾驶的1962年吉普角斗士。埃米尔开始透过挡风玻璃向吉普车开枪。
And that was enough for Bill to stop and get out and run. Emil pulled up next to the Jeep. He got out and dumped his weapons and ammo into it. He got out and dumped his weapons and ammo into it. He got in and attempted to drive off, but he couldn't get the car started. And it was at this time that a police car containing three SWAT officers. Don Anderson, Steve Gomez and Richard Massa were flying down Archwood Street towards Emil. Emil was now in the Jeep facing west on Archwood.
这就足以让比尔停下车并下车逃跑了。埃米尔把车停在吉普车旁。他下车，把武器和弹药扔进吉普车里。他下车，把武器和弹药扔进吉普车里。他上车并试图开车离开，但车怎么也发动不起来。正是在这个时候，载着三名特警队员的警车——唐·安德森、史蒂夫·戈麦斯和理查德·马萨——正沿着阿特伍德街向埃米尔疾驰而来。埃米尔此时在吉普车里，面向阿特伍德街的西边。
The SWAT officers were heading east. So they were head on. In an incredibly brave move, he just drove straight at Emil. Pulling out the car at an angle directly in front of the Jeep. When he saw the SWAT officers pull up, Emil jumped out and took cover back behind the chef. So there was only about 30 feet or 10 meters distance between the SWAT officers and Emil. And there were three cars in between them. They then engaged in a fierce gun battle.
特警队员正向东行驶。所以他们是正面迎敌。在一个极其勇敢的举动中，他直接向埃米尔开车冲过去。把车斜停在吉普车正前方。当看到特警队员把车停下时，埃米尔跳出车外，躲回雪佛兰后面。所以特警队员和埃米尔之间的距离只有大约30英尺或10米。他们之间隔着三辆车。随后他们爆发了一场激烈的枪战。
Went down Archwood. Shot fired, shot fired, shot fired. More shots of being fired, shots of being fired. Watch for crossfire, watch for crossfire. All units, watch for crossfire. On Archwood between Raptor and Hyde, Metro is engaging the suspect. All units, stay back. On Archwood between Raptor and Hyde, Air Unit advise all officers stay back.
沿着阿特伍德过去。有枪声，有枪声，有枪声。有更多枪声响起，有枪声响起。注意交叉火力，注意交叉火力。所有单位，注意交叉火力。在猛禽路和海德路之间的阿特伍德街上，大都会分局正在与嫌疑人交火。所有单位，退后。在猛禽路和海德路之间的阿特伍德街上，空中单位建议所有警员退后。
Watch for crossfire. Emil was struck several times, but was saved by his body armor yet again. It didn't take the SWAT officers long to realise that if they fired underneath the vehicles, they would be able to hit the legs of Emil, which weren't protected by body armor. Their plan worked. They hit Emil multiple times in the legs. One bullet actually shattered his leg. But still, Emil wasn't giving up.
注意交叉火力。埃米尔中了好几枪，但又一次被他的防弹衣救了。特警队员们没花多久就意识到，如果他们射击车辆下方，就能击中埃米尔没有防弹衣保护的腿部。他们的计划成功了。他们击中了埃米尔腿部的多个部位。一颗子弹甚至粉碎了他的腿。然而，埃米尔并没有放弃。
He kept trying to fire at the SWAT officers. The SWAT officers didn't know what to do. He kept trying to fire at the SWAT officers. But SWAT were winning the battle. Emil was hit several more times and eventually they finally stopped him. Emil collapsed dropping his weapon and SWAT pounced on him. That exchange lasted just under two minutes. The time was now 10.01 am.
他继续试图向特警队员开枪。特警队员不知道该怎么办。他继续试图向特警队员开枪。但特警队正在赢得这场战斗。埃米尔又中了好几枪，最终他们彻底制服了他。埃米尔瘫倒在地，扔下了武器，特警队员扑了上去。那场交火持续了不到两分钟。当时时间是上午10点01分。
After 44 minutes of mayhem, the North Hollywood shootout was over. But the scene was obviously still chaotic. Injured officers and injured civilians everywhere. And the police still weren't entirely sure if they had all the gunmen or if they had a gunman or a gunman. The scene and surrounding areas wouldn't be fully cleared until over 12 hours later. Emil was down, but he was still alert. He was placed under the guard of detectives James Bodge-Teckey and Officer John Futrell.
经过44分钟的混乱，北好莱坞枪战结束了。但现场显然仍然一片混乱。受伤的警察和受伤的平民到处都是。而且警方仍然不完全确定他们是否已经制服了所有枪手，或者他们面对的是一个还是多个枪手。现场及周边地区直到12个多小时后才完全清理完毕。埃米尔倒下了，但他仍然保持清醒。他被置于探员詹姆斯·博奇-泰基和约翰·富特雷尔警官的看守之下。
Emil had been shot 29 times. He stayed alive for more than a year. He was shot in the head. Emil had been shot 29 times. He stayed alive for just over an hour, but an ambulance never got to him in time. And he died at the scene. He was aged 30 years old. A few years later, Emil's family filed a civil suit against the LAPD
埃米尔身上中了29枪。他活了一年多。他头部中枪。埃米尔身上中了29枪。他活了一个多小时一点，但救护车从来没有及时赶到他身边。他在现场死亡。他年仅30岁。几年后，埃米尔的家属对洛杉矶警察局（LAPD）提起了民事诉讼，
and specifically the two officers who were guarding him. The LAPD responded by saying it was standard procedure not to allow paramedics into what was called the hot zone, putting them in danger. They maintained they were of the belief that there was at least one and possibly more gunmen still on the loose. It was alleged in the court case that paramedics had made their way to Emil's location while he was still alive, but one of the officers told them to leave. It is also alleged other paramedics were heading that way,
特别指控了当时看守他的两名警官。洛杉矶警察局的回应是，不允许医护人员进入所谓的“热区”以防他们陷入危险，这是标准程序。他们坚信当时至少还有一名、甚至可能有多名枪手在逃。法庭诉讼中指控称，当埃米尔还活着的时候，医护人员已经到达了他的所在地，但其中一名警官叫他们离开。还有人指控其他医护人员正朝着那个方向赶去，
but their attendance was cancelled by Officer Futrell over the air. Some people say they deliberately let him die. The LAPD maintained that they were following standard procedure. The jury couldn't decide. The case resulted in a hung jury. After that result, Emil's family ended up dropping their civil suit. During that 44 minutes, Emil and Larry had fired about 1100 rounds. The police had fired about 650 rounds.
但富特雷尔警官通过电台取消了他们的出勤。有人说他们是故意让他死的。洛杉矶警察局坚称他们遵循的是标准程序。陪审团无法做出决定。该案件导致陪审团陷入僵局。结果出来后，埃米尔的家属最终撤回了民事诉讼。在那44分钟里，埃米尔和拉里发射了大约1100发子弹。警察发射了大约650发子弹。
Over 300 police officers attended in what was a city-wide tactical alert. 32 officers in total fired their weapons at Emil and Larry at one point or another. 17 officers were awarded the Medal of Valour, which is the LAPD's highest honour, awarded for bravery or heroism above and beyond the normal demands of police service. A total of 11 police and seven civilians were injured. But by some miracle, the only people that lost their lives that day were Larry Phillips Jr. and Emil Matasarano. Copyright © 2020 Mooji Media Ltd. All Rights Reserved.
超过300名警察参加了这次全市范围的战术戒严。总共有32名警察在某个时刻向埃米尔和拉里开枪。17名警察被授予勇气勋章，这是洛杉矶警察局的最高荣誉，授予那些表现出超越警察职责日常要求的勇敢或英雄主义的行为。总共有11名警察和7名平民受伤。但通过某种奇迹，那天失去生命的仅有小拉里·菲利普斯和埃米尔·马塔萨拉诺。版权所有 © 2020 Mooji Media Ltd. 保留所有权利。
No part of this recording may be reproduced without Mooji Media Ltd.'s express consent. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
未经 Mooji Media Ltd. 明确同意，不得复制本录音的任何部分。本集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。